[Musique]
David Lisnard, bonsoir. Bonsoir. Nous
vous recevons pour une chaîne internet
qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous sommes en
direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succintement ? Je m'appelle
donc David Lissard. Je suis un citoyen
français âgé de 56 ans de sexe masculin,
géniteur de trois enfants et un 4e dans
mon giron de parentalité, on va dire. Et
après plusieurs fonctions, métier, je
j'exerce le mandat notamment de maire de
Cann.
Vous êtes président de l'association des
maires ? Oui. Combien ça représente de
maires ? Ça représente quasiment tous
les maires de France. Alors, il y en a
moins qu'avant parce qu'il y a eu des
communes nouvelles qui ont été inventées
par la MF d'ailleurs, par Jack
Pellissard qui était un de mes
prédécesseurs qui m'a qui m'a appris
beaucoup de choses. J'ai eu la chance de
travailler avec lui quand j'étais jeune.
Et donc aujourd'hui, on est 35000 maires
en France, 3485
et quasiment 100 % sont adhérents de la
MF ainsi que les présidents
d'intercommunalité.
Vous allez vous présenter au
présidentiel ?
Je me prépare à la présidentielle parce
que je me prépare à proposer une
alternative qui en finisse avec 40 ou 50
ans de de socialtatisme. Et alors est-ce
que j'aurai la capacité d'eux ? Il y a
que les fous qui pensent qu' en partant
d'où je pars, ils peuvent être
candidats. Mais en tout cas, je fais
tout et la preuve, je vous réponds aussi
pour porter une alternative libérale,
sécuritaire, éducative, scientifique.
Aujourd'hui, on va vous faire une
interview
chef de l'État. On va rentrer dans les
détails sur des questions de
géopolitique, de finances, peut-être de
sécurité, peut-être de prospective.
Première question que je vais vous
poser.
Vous avez vous allez avoir vos
parrainages au fait ?
Ça ira. Je pense que ça sera pas la plus
grosse difficulté. Si j'en suis à ce à
ce problème là, ça veut dire j'aurais
franchi quelques étapes. J'en suis à
chercher les parrainages. Bon alors
en terme de prospective, vous vous
identifiez quoi comme danger à 1 2 et 5
ans pour la France ? Alors déjà, il y a
des dangers euh qui sont même pas à un
an, qui sont immédiats. Euh aujourd'hui.
Le le déclassement éducatif qui est le
plus gros problème à mon sens, le
délitement euh sécuritaire, euh le le le
déclin relatif, en tout cas économique,
euh l'effondrement démographique dont on
parle peu mais qui est peut-être le
premier problème avec l'éducatif. Bref,
je pourrais en citer d'autres, les
défis, enfin tout ça, on est dedans. On
est dedans. Au moment où je vous
réponds, on a encore une jeune femme qui
s'est fait trucider dans dans un collège
en France, quoi. Enfin, je bon voilà.
Euh mais il y a évidemment des dangers
ou des opportunités, en tout cas des
défis extrêmement forts à relever, je
viens de les citer. Défis
démographiques, défis économiqu, défis
numérique. C'est la base de tout
aujourd'hui. Défi de l'intelligence
artificielle, de la quantique, défis
écologique évidemment. Et le problème
pour la France, le danger pour rester
sur votre approche, c'est ils sont de
plusieurs ordres. Il y a évidemment un
danger de relégation économique et
lorsqu'on ne crée plus assez de
richesse, on a plus les moyens de son
rayonnement et de son indépendance. Il y
a le danger donc de cette relégation
scientifique et éducative qui qui
m'obsède un petit peu, je dois l'avouer.
Et puis il y a des menaces extérieur,
c'est-à-dire que vous avez des empires
illibéraux
voire dictatoriaux qui sont de plus en
plus menaçants et qui retrouvent une
leur réalité reptilienne, c'est-à-dire
expansionniste, l'empire russe, l'empire
chinois. Même si on dit que la Chine
n'est jamais dans la conquête, moi je je
pense qu'il faut regarder ça avec plus
de prudence. euh des empires à la fois
faibles et forts comme l'Iran qui est
euh qui est pas loin de de la de la de
la bombe atomique. Un empire qui est qui
s'affaiblit un peu sur le plan intérieur
politique mais qui qui est un empire
avec un chef d'état extrêmement habile
qui est qui est la Turquie, l'ancien
Empire ottoman.
Donc il y a ces dangers extérieurs et
puis il y a l'islamisme qui est une
internationale
forte
qui s'appuie sur une dynamique
d'immigration donc interne en Europe
mais qui s'appuie aussi sur la faiblesse
morale, spirituelle, culturelle, une
espèce de fatigue civique et morale de
de l'Europe et de la France. Donc ces
dangers là, ils sont majeurs. Ouais.
Donc là, on se trouve au milieu du gay,
peut-être au milieu de l'ornière. On a
Emmanuel Macron qui nous a fait 1000
milliards de dettes en plus.
euh qui était censé faire 60 milliards
d'économies par an, qui était censé euh
nous enlever
les SDF, reloger les SDF, arrêter
d'avoir des enfants dans la rue. Euh
vous vous présentez à la présidence,
vous êtes pas un peu psychopathe de
récupérer un navire qui est déjà en
train de prendre la flotte ?
C'est non parce que c'est pas me
présenter la présidence ou pas. Je sais
que je on est citoyen français et et moi
en tant que citoyen français quand quand
on me dit la dépense publique
la dette publique chaque français doit
participer. On participe déjà par
définition ce qui est public c'est nous
tous. Je je suis sidéré de de ce
distingo qui est fait entre les vraies
personnes et et la dette publique, la
dépense publique, l'effondrement des
comptes publics. Tout ça est très lié.
Euh donc euh à un moment donné, il faut
essayer d'y croire et de prendre notre
destin en main. Moi je je refuse ce
fatalisme, cette fatalité. Je suis père
de famille, je je me suis présenté ainsi
tout à l'heure et et il y a deux choses
qui me qui me motivent, qui me donnent
encore le l'énergie de de de faire cela
de de m'engager dans cette vie publique
pour laquelle j'étais pas prédestiné.
Un, c'est que je pense que la France a
quelque chose de très particulier à dire
dans le 21e siècle. On y reviendra
peut-être mais c'est notamment il me
semble de ce que je peux voir de de
français qui sortent de grandes écoles
ou de français autodidactes qui vont à
l'étranger qu'on qu'on est peut-être un
peu parmi les plus créatifs du monde
pour plein de raisons et dans le 21e
siècle la créativité va être un atout
considérable. Deuxème élément donc j'ai
envie que la France rayonne. Je veux ce
pays qui qui est beau qui est c'est
c'est il faut la ressentir la France.
Enfin, quand vous sentez la la force de
du granit en Bretagne ou en Corse ou en
Limousin, que vous regardez les signes
des Almes, euh quand vous regardez la
beauté de la Méditerranée, la beauté de
nos grandes villes et cetera, je quand
vous vous voyez la la puissance de
l'OBRAC, ça c'est c'est les pirlide la
France, c'est beau, c'est une
géographie, c'est aussi une histoire, un
peuple qui qui s'est forgé dans avec
l'État, hein, notamment. Mais en tout
cas, c'est c'est nous sommes un beau et
grand pays qui a se cassé par d'ombre
comme toute nation, mais qui a inventé
de belles choses de grands juristes, de
grands entrepreneurs, de grands
scientifiques, de grands artistes, euh
de grands agriculteurs et cetera. Et
donc le on ne peut pas abandonner ça et
on se doit de de de de de faire rayonner
la France et parallèlement juste pour
terminer pardon pardonnez-moi je vais
répondre à la question mais et et j'ai
des enfants et je voudrais que mes
enfants puissent avoir une espérance de
France que et j'espère futurs petits
enfants puissent se projeter en en se
disant on va vivre nous allons vivre
dans un pays prospère libre et sûr et
c'est cette prospérité cette liberté
cette sécurité qu'il faut retrouver
qu'est-ce que la France a inventé dans
mis à part des taxes des vieux et de la
parole diplomatique sacagé. Euh oui ou
du discours euh performatif quoi que
sans sans effet euh qu'un filet d'eau
tiède mais euh oui mais parallèlement
euh la France a aussi euh des des des
chercheurs encore même si on manque
d'ingénieurs qui sont parmi les
meilleurs au monde en robotique mais
après le problème c'est qu'ils s'en
vont. Euh on a eu des mathématiciens, on
a on produit encore des mathématiciens
mais malheureusement qu'ils s'en vont.
Beaucoup de tax Non mais enfin c'est le
cœur de ça fait partie du cœur de de mon
propos. c'est qu'on produit de de la
taxe de la norme de la règle. On
surtransporte les normes européennes et
euh on produit surtout peut-être pire
que tout de la procédure du du process.
C'est ce que décrit très bien, y compris
dans le milieu de l'entreprise Juliet
Funess, la philosophe,
cette espèce de de frénésie de la
procédure et du process. Et évidemment,
nous sommes les plus créatifs en terme
d'invention de de de
taxes. Mais à côté de ça, nous créons
nous avons des une grande littérature,
encore un grand cinéma euh et et une
grande potentialité. Donc le le on est,
vous savez, j'utilise souvent cette
métaphore quand quand je fais des
réunions y compris d'appartement comme
on dit. Euhware ouais ouais, j'en fais
bien sûr. Et euh parce que ça permis de
confronter les idées de de et cetera.
Mais le on est dans dans le match dans
le film de The Wood Island Match Point,
il y a la balle de tennis, elle peut
tomber d'un côté ou de l'autre du filet.
Donc on peut tomber du côté vraiment de
l'effondrement et de la violence comme
l'histoire de France malheureusement
en a souvent été le théâtre. Et on peut
aussi tomber du côté d'un d'un vrai
sursaut.
On peut être en 1958,
l'État de la France en 58 était
calamiteux he l'effondrement de la 4e
République. Alors il y a pas le général
de Gaul en tout cas il y a plus l'empire
et oui puis il y a pas le général de
Gaul mais l'empire à l'époque était
plutôt devenait plutôt un problème. Mais
c'estàdire un des problèmes qu'il
fallait relever un des défis qu'il
fallait relever de l'époque. Mais bon on
peut avoir une force civique, il faut
encore y croire et parallèlement on peut
tomber du côté de la violence comme en
1848. Et il y a des simbilitudes aussi
avec 1848. C'est-à-dire un chef d'état
qui qui est déconnecté des élites qui
sont ultra conformistes. Moi, c'est ce
qui me frappe. C'est c'est pour ça que
je veux pas lâcher le morceau parce que
je je suis quelqu'un de légitimiste, on
va dire, mais j'ai découvert à quel
point j'ai j'ai toujours une haute idée
de la chose publique. J'ai voulu en
faire et et à quel point on a euh il
faut des élites. Il y a pas il peut pas
y avoir de prospérité de nations sans
élite, mais il faut que ces élites elles
soient régénérées, qu'elles soient
ouvertes sur la société et on se rend
compte qu' une espèce d'aristocratie
d'État qui s'est mise en place. Donc je
pense qu'on est à la fin d'un effet de
cycle et c'est là qu'il faut essayer de
proposer une alternative de la volonté,
une alternative de de l'effort, une
alternative
de l'optimisme de la volonté comme
disait le philosophe Alain et ça paraît
très généraliste mais mais on peut le
détailler. C'est ce qu'on va faire, je
crois. On a le temps.
Donc pour faire des bonnes prospectives,
des bons caps et ne pas naviguer à fu
comme nos services de renseignement,
il faut faire le bon constat. Le
constat, il en est où pour Davis Lisnard
? Le constat dans quel domaine ? Ah oui,
le constat géopolitique, le constat
énergétique, le constat matière
première, le constat technologique. Oui.
Et on peut ajouter le constat
alimentaire agricole. Oui, ça va de soi.
C'est c'est de la c'est de la calorie.
Donc si c'est de la calorie, on met ça
dans le département énergie. Énergie.
alimentation sont vraiment deux éléments
fondamentaux
de la prospective et de la souveraineté
et de la capacité d'une nation à choisir
son destin. Euh le constat, il est il
est assez calamiteux
en réalité quand on regarde
l'effondrement depuis une cinquantaine
d'années. Donc il faut savoir le
regarder en face de dans mon dernier
ouvrage euh qui donc s'appelle Invival
la France et manifeste libéral. Je je
commence par cette citation de Peggy.
Euh c'est une des rares citations de
d'ouvrage qui est très connu. Il faut
savoir voir ce que l'on voit, voir ce
que l'on voit et dire ce que l'on voit.
Mais le plus dur, c'est de voir ce que
l'on voit. Donc économique, nous étions
nous étions euh au 27e rang. Nous nous
étions pardon au 7e rang en PIB par
habitant. C'estàd en somme de valeurs
ajoutées. C'est quoi l'économie ? C'est
la création de richesse. C'est la somme
des C'est la valeur ajoutée. C'est
l'énergie transformée. C'est l'énergie
transformée. Donc l'économie c'est il y
a deux facteurs de production. tout
part-d le capital et le travail,
l'investissement et le le travail qui
est une force physique ou mentale. Et de
ces deux facteurs de production n une
création de valeur, création de richesse
qui va déterminer tout le reste. Donc la
création de richesse, le PIB, c'est pas
une abstraction, c'est absolument
essentiel. Le nous étions donc au 7e
rang il y a 30 ans par habitant de
création de valeur. Nous sommes
aujourd'hui au 27e rang par habitant.
Donc 30 ans, c'est très court. Euh je de
mémoire ainsi que Juglar, c'est 10 ans,
quoi. Donc c'est c'est très court. Sur
le plan euh sur le plan l'économie,
c'est aussi une réalité humaine.
C'est-à-dire que on entend les débats
sur le pouvoir d'achat et c'est pour ça
que le social et l'économie sont
profondément liés. Pas de politique
sociale sans prospérité économique. Il
faut pas, il vaut mieux répartir la
richesse que répartir la pauvreté. Et le
le le débat sur le pouvoir d'achat,
c'est d'abord un débat sur le revenu
disponible.
Or, le différentiel entre le super brut
et le net est le plus élevé du monde. Et
c'est là la clé de tout. C'est là,
j'utilise souvent cette expression qui
avait fait le titre d'un ouvrage de de
de Pompidou, le Nogordien qu'il nous
faut trancher aujourd'hui. C'est celui
de la performance de la nation pour
réduire
la la calandre bureaucratique en général
à travers des prélèvements fiscaux et
sociaux qui nécessitent des prélèvements
fiscaux et sociaux pour permettre
d'avoir une plus grande compétitivité
sur les facteurs de production. donc
d'avoir des entreprises compétitives par
rapport au moins au reste de l'Europe et
d'avoir à la fin un salarié dont le
salaire net est plus élevé, donc d'avoir
plus de salaire net et moins de de super
brut. Donc tout est là et ça on pourra
je sais pas mais on pourra peut-être le
décortiquer. Le donc le constat social
c'est qu'il faut d'abord recréer une
énergie de du de la création de
richesse, de valeur par
l'investissement,
par le travail. Donc bonne formation,
accès aux capitaux, capacité de financer
l'économie, ça renvoie à une multitude
de sujets. Deuxième constat pour pour
pas faire trop de digression et et sur
votre votre question, le constat
démographique, c'est que nous étions un
des pays occidentaux qui résistait le
mieux en terme de natalité et
qu'aujourd'hui notre natalité
s'effondre. Donc nous avons un effet de
ciseau démographique qui est
catastrophique. Pourquoi elle s'effondre
? Euh alors s'effondre
euh
il faut il faut avoir l'humilité de
savoir que on n' jamais ce on n'est
jamais sûr de la capacité de retrouve
d'avoir une politique publique qui soit
vraiment porteuse de démographie hein
euh parce qu'il faut faire la différence
entre corrélation, coïncidence,
causalité. Il est vrai qu'avant on avait
une politique familiale qui était
proactive qui avait été conçue par
Michel Debré à l'époque sous le le le
président de Gaul et que cette politique
familiale a été mise à mal notamment
sous le président Hollande et qu'il y a
en tout cas
corrélation coïncidence entre les deux.
Est-ce qu'il y a causalité ? Il y a des
débats là-dessus. Ce qui est sûr, c'est
que
et là c'est plus subjectif,
euh on a remis en cause l'universalité
des politiques familiale. Premier
élément. Deuxième élément,
on a des difficultés parfois de facilité
pour des femmes qui travaillent pour
élever les enfants, donc de l'accès à
des crèches, même si c'est moins
difficile qu'on le pense dans beaucoup
de dans beaucoup de villes ou dans
beaucoup de secteurs. Euh je je crois,
mais je le répète, c'est subjectif.
que cela traduit surtout une crise
morale très forte et que les
collapsologues, les millénaristes, tous
ceux qui prennent la décroissance, c'est
quoi un collapsologue ? C'est ceux qui
euh voi la fin du monde dans la
croissance. Espèce d'oxymorque, c'est
pas un peu résumé d'une façon très
triviale ça ? Si. Oui, c'est une façon
aussi de de d'argumenter. C'est-à-dire
que la trivialité, c'est pas un
argument. Euh si ça peut être,
pardonnez-moi, mais il me semble que la
trivalité peut être une façon de de
faire de la de l'accouchement d'idée, de
faire de la maillotique comme on disait
de façon pompeuse. Alors, j'ai pas la
prétention de d'être Aristote ou
Socrate, hein. Mais mais pour revenir à
ça, c'estd que la le le doute qui est un
doute existentiel, on parlait tout à
l'heure de menace, hein. Le fait qui
consiste à ne pas voir dans un enfant
une source de de une comment dire sans
tomber dans l'enface dans dans
l'exagération mais une une quelque chose
de magique de beau, une joie mais de
voir dans l'enfant un élément de
pollution ou de contrainte
professionnelle
de contrainte financière ou de
contrainte financière. Sauf que euh vous
remarquerez que euh les ce sont souvent
des personnes plutôt bien établies
financièrement qui font de moins en
moins d'enfants et que l'effondrement
quand alors c'est peut-être
contreintuitif mais c'est une réalité et
que l'effondrement enfin la baisse
démographique elle est notamment vraie
dans les grandes villes. Donc je pense
que le problème du logement de façon
très matérielle est un vrai sujet, c'est
un sujet majeur. Mais il n'empêche que
quand vous regardez et et c'est et c'est
une réalité qui n'est pas que une
observation
empirique ou une réalité qui qui
d'expérience quoi. Enfin moi je sais pas
ma grand-mère qui était mieux très
maternelle qui était mieux très modeste
très modeste a eu neuf enfants. À
l'époque les familles très pauvres
faisaient des enfants. Il y avait quand
même une ont survécu. Oui. et une il y
avait une oui il y avait une une quand
même une espèce de de croyance dans le
progrès que les conditions de vie
s'améliorer et puis on se posait
peut-être un peu moins de questions. Bon
donc le le le discours de la
décroissance à mon avis fait beaucoup de
dégâts fait beaucoup de dégâts, détruit
beaucoup d'esprit et puis ensuite on
voit bien que parmi les conditions de
vie qui se sont détériorées, c'est
vraiment le logement, ça c'est sûr. On a
de moins en moins ces grandes maisons où
il y avait plusieurs générations. Ça
pose aussi un problème d'ailleurs du
traitement des vieux. hein, des
personnes âgées de la génération, la
solidarité intergénérationnelle. Alors,
d'autres pays ont un effondrement
démographique et traite bien leur vieux
dans les familles. Par exemple, l'Italie
qui fait moins d'enfants que nous, où la
personne ASG est encore traitée dans la
famille, nous on est entre deux
systèmes. Donc, je si je reviens à votre
question, les fondements démographiques,
on pourra l'évoquer. Je Il y a quand
même des choses à faire pour essayer de
retrouver une ambition démographique.
Je sais pas si vous voulez que j'y
réponde maintenant ou plus tard. euh
dans les constat
donc l'économie, la démographie, le le
social qui qui sont liés. La
démographie, c'est important aussi parce
que on a fondé notre système social sur
une pyramide qui devient maintenant une
pyramide de Pondzi, c'est une pyramide
inversée. On a fondé notre système
social, notamment notre système de
retraite sur une croissance
démographique. La retraite dite par
répartition qui fait que l'actif actuel
paye pour le retraité actuel et que le
futur actif payera pour l'actif actuel.
Euh donc c'est une solidarité
intergénérationnelle est un système qui
peut fonctionner quand il y a des gains
de productivité et quand il y a des
gains démographiques. Or, c'est tout le
contraire aujourd'hui puisqu'il a été
conçu dans les années 40. Il est rentré
en en fonctionnement de façon pleine et
entière des années 50 60 70 et il y a
encore 50 ans, 50 ans, il y avait
presque cinq actifs, c'est-à-dire
cotisants par retraité bénéficiaire.
nous allons vers 1,5 actifs par
bénéficiaire.
Donc il y a un effet de ciseau
démographique aussi sur la médecine où
comme on vieillit la population âgée de
plus en plus nombreuse et et on sait que
il y a une explosion des coûts de santé
avec l'âge. Il il y a trois facteurs qui
expliquent l'explosion des coûts de la
santé, le vieillissement de la
population, la chronicité croissante des
maladies et l'exigence de technologie.
Donc vous avez un effet de ciseau qui
fait que la demande explose et l'offre
elle à cause des technocrate
incompétents qui ont décidé le numéros
clausus à l'époque la la l'offre et et
ce système qui a flingué enfin en tout
cas qui a attaqué la médecine de ville,
la médecine libérale et qui a tout
renvoyé vers l'hôpital qui qui est un
vrai problème pour l'hôpital et pour la
médecine de ville fait qu'aujourd'hui on
a des déserts médicaux dans l'immense
majorité du pays. Donc voyez, la
démographie c'est un élément très très
important. Ensuite évidemment il y a le
constat numérique.
Nous avons nous sommes, nous devenons
France et Europe nous une colonie
numérique de la Chine des États-Unis.
C'est pour moi ce n'est pas acceptable.
Euh nous avons l'essentiel des données
qui sont maîtrisées par des gars femmes.
Euh nous n'avons aucune maîtrise des
flux du web puisque désormais de mémoire
mais je tout le monde pourra vérifier 90
% des de la bande passante se fait par
600 câbles sous-marins qui appartiennent
dont aucun n'appartient à la France. Un
devrait passer par la Polynésie
française mais aucun n'appartient à la
France. Euh 10 % restant, ça doit être
le très haut débit par par le
satellitaire. Donc c'est un enjeu
majeur, mais je pourrais le le le nous
avions vous vous m'avez cité l'énergie
l'énergie la France a a eu un génie
une vision euh sur le nucléaire et sur
l'hydroélectrique. Nous avons été parmi
les meilleurs du monde sur l'énergie
nucléaire et sur l'énergie
hydroélectrique qui sont les deux
meilleures énergies
qui répondent aux enjeux du 21e siècle.
même si cette effort technologique a été
fait notamment les années 60 70 et qui
donc pour l'électrification,
c'est une énergie décarbonée,
pilotable, abondante notamment le
nucléaire et bon marché. Je peux vous
arrêter ? Oui, bien sûr, bien sûr. Donc
pour l'énergie, on dit merci à Bernard
Zambert. Euh là, on est en train de
caresser l'écume des choses. Bah, vous
me demandez le constat. Je On rentre
dans pas très longtemps dans le détail.
Je vous laisse terminer sur l'énergie.
OK. Donc bon, énergie aujourd'hui euh on
voit bien que la doxa que nous que enfin
que nos dirigeants se sont laissés
imposé depuis une dizaine d'années fait
que euh sous un prisme idéologique euh
d'une d'une bienpensance européenne, euh
on a voulu imposer un mix énergétique au
lieu de conformer nos avantages
compétitifs qui correspondent
parfaitement à l'exigence de
décarbonation et de pilotable
électrique. Aujourd'hui, on a mis en
place des investissements donc sans
jamais calculer le rapport coût avantage
en profit d'énergie du renouvelable
contre lesquels je n'ai rien, il en faut
aussi mais dont on fait une architecture
prioritaire et c'est le cas de du
prochain plan de de de énergétique avec
300 milliards d'investissements là où on
manque d'investissement pour relancer
notre nucléaire qui a été saccagé par un
accord électoral entre les écologistes
et François Hollande et qui a été
confirmé par Emmanuel Macron lorsqu'il a
décidé de fermer Fessonheim. Euh
souvenez-vous, c'était dès 2017, il a
confirmé cette fermeture et c'était à
celui qui revendiquait la fermeture de
FM entre lui, son premier ministre de
l'époque et sa ministre de
l'environnement de l'époque et qu'il
fait voter une loi de transition
énergétique qui prévoit la fermeture de
14 réacteurs nucléaires au moment où au
contraire il faudra un plan énergétique
mondial. Donc euh voilà quelques
constats et puis bien sûr le classement
éducatif.
Euh nous nous sommes aujourd'hui euh
parmi les pays les moins performants de
d'après toutes les études. Il y a la
PISA qui est connue mais aussi études
Teams. Il y a aussi les études
d'ailleurs de l'éducation nationale sur
euh ce qui est essentiel notamment les
mathématiques. Les mathématiques sont de
plus en plus essentielles dans tous les
domaines sur la maîtrise de la langue
sur le français. Euh et euh donc
là-dessus euh notre enfin nous devons
avoir une ambition de devenir une
superpuissance éducative. C'est tout à
fait dans les moyens de la France.
On arrête de caresser l'écume des
choses. On rentre dans le détail. Je
termine par je commence par la fin de
votre
phrase. L'Europe, le programme
énergétique, la doxa, le conformisme. La
question que je vais vous poser, c'est
vos connaissances en terme de guerre
économique, le fait que les Allemands
nous ont fait systématiquement des
crochep pour anéantir notre force
nucléaire qu'elle jugeit comme trop
compétitive par rapport à à son
économie.
On fait quoi ? Si vous êtes président
demain, vous tapez du point sur la
table, vous sortez de l'Europe, vous
expliquez aux Allemands qu'ils ont été
méchants avec nous, qu'il faut qu'il
paye un petit peu. Là, on fait quoi en
terme diplomatique ? Énergétiquement
parlant, on sort, on reste, on continue,
on vend notre énergie 15 fois trois fois
plus cher. On fait comment ? On continue
de stabiliser le parc, la grille
énergétique européenne avec nos
centrales nucléaires quitte à les user
plus rapidement. Qu'est-ce qu'on fait
avec le président Lisnard ? Le
lendemain, son ministre de l'énergie
déjà qui qu'est-ce qu'il va faire ?
Quelle quelle va être sa doctrine
souverainiste énergétique ? En sachant
que les Russes nous ferment le robinet,
les Chinois nous ferment le robinet, les
Américains nous ouvrent le robinet mais
cinq fois plus cher, que on est un peu
fâché avec les Algériens, que ça devient
un peu compliqué et que vous n'avez pas
ça vous a pas échappé que PIB dès que
l'énergie de la consommation énergétique
décroit, notre PIB décroit avec. Alors
il y a c'est plus qu'une corrélation,
c'est une causalité. l'énergie et le
facteur essentiel de capacité de
production. La guerre énergétique, elle
est essentielle. 1 2 euh nous devons et
nous dépendons encore beaucoup des
énergies fossiles. C'est ce qu'on parce
qu'on parle toujours du nucléaire, des
de l'éolienne et et du solaire mais on
oublie de dire qu'aujourd'hui nous
importons l'essentiel de énergie
fossile. Ces énergies fossiles sont
encore extrêmement présentes et et pour
un bout de temps. Donc l'enjeu, il est
comme toujours semble-t-il d'aller sur
ses avantages compétitifs. C'est c'est
du David Ricardo qui qui reste
pertinent. Donc l'enjeu c'est évidemment
de concentrer nos investissements sur
l'intérêt de la nation française qui est
de développer son indépendance
électrique et sa capacité électrique de
le développer sur une énergie pilotable,
décarbonée,
abondante, bon marché. Donc c'est sur le
nucléaire et l'hydroélectrique. Quel
type de réacteur ? Alors aujourd'hui, on
est euh bon, les 6 heures repères qui
ont été annoncés euh sont euh sont très
bienvenus, mais on sait très bien qu'il
faut aller sur des réacteurs de plus
petites dimension, qu'on a pris un
énorme retard pour des raisons
doctrinales, hein. Et euh la là-dessus,
euh c'est c'est pas à moi de le dire
parce que vous disiez tout à l'heure, on
va rentrer dans le détail puisque vous
me faites l'honneur de considérer que je
suis un présidential, mais je pense que
justement c'est pas un présidential
d'aller dans tous les détails. Le
présidentiel, c'est celui qui sait se
renseigner, qui sait prendre les
décisions et qui est constant dans ses
principes. Vous êtes renseigné sur la
disponibilité de la ressource en uranium
? Oui. Oui. Oui. Oui. Et vous êtes
enseigné auprès de qui ? Je alors j'ai
dans Nouvelle énergie, c'est le cas le
nom de mon parti politique, un certain
nombre de de de conseillers en je sais
pas si je s'ils accepteraient que je
dise leur nom puisque certains sont sont
très actifs dans actuellement mais qui
qui qui turbinent, c'est le cas de le
dire euh dans dans ces domaines là. Et
j'essaie j'essaie de me j'essaie de me
former. Après, moi j'ai j'ai juste un
truc, c'est que euh de la ressource,
c'est pas Oui, c'est pas une c'est pas
du tout une martingal et cetera. Mais
moi, je prétends absolument pas avoir la
la réponse à toutes ces questions-là
quantitativement. C'est pas question
pour un champion, quoi. Euh c'est pour
ça il faut inviter unarc, il faut
inviter quelqu'un comme ça. Voilà ce
qu'il faut lesarc savent pas ce qui est
ce qu'il faut. J'espère qu' mo qu'
savent des choses quand même, mais le le
ce qui est essentiel à un moment donné,
c'est de poser une vision, une
stratégie, ensuite de voir quel moyen on
peut mettre et puis de l'évaluer et
d'aller dans l'exécution. parce que
c'est l'exécution des choses qui compte.
Bon, donc euh aujourd'hui euh dans dans
le dans le nucléaire, on s il faut
réorienter nos investissements de façon
prioritaire dans le nucléaire et laisser
la subsidiarité, c'est-à-dire que
l'architecture du réseau électrique qui
doit être interconnecté avec le reste de
l'Europe parce que c'est c'est à mon
avis nécessaire, doit être notamment sur
le nucléaire, essentiellement sur le
nucléaire, sur l'électrique et c'est
cette puissance électrique qui doit nous
permettre de renégocier des accords
internationaux sur les hydrocarbures.
Aujourd'hui, on a remplacé notre
dépendance au gaz russe. C'est une
dépendance désormais au gaz américain,
au gaz liquide américain.
De façon manifeste, hein, en 3 ans, il y
a eu un basculement y compris au gaz de
chiste puisque on s'est interdit la
recherche même sur les nouvelles
technologies de fragmentation dans
produire du gaz de chist. Quelles
conséquences pour l'économie européenne
? Bah, c'est une c'est un déclassement
considérable puisque depuis 10 ans on a
perdu 40 % de PIB par rapport aux
États-Unis. Parce que c'est un double
winwin à la fois pour les Russes et les
Américains. Ouais. C'est-à-dire qu'on
est en train de dépesser l'Europe, nos
entreprises se sont en train de se faire
acheter à bas prix et on est en train de
faire de la dette à Gogo qui est en
train de nous passer le nœud autour de
la gorge. Est-ce que nos élites Est-ce
que vos élites que vous avez recruté ont
senti le couvenir ? Pourquoi vos élites
que vous avez recruté ? Je comprends pas
bien. Dans votre dans votre partie. Ah,
il y a bien il y a bien du jus de
cerveau qui est en train de s'organiser.
Oui, oui, oui, oui. Il y a du jus de
cerveau. Oui, oui. Mais parce que c'est
votre lecture qu'on est en train de se
faire. Si ces gens-là sont venus vers
moi, c'est parce que précisément ils se
sont rendus compte d'une part que avec
un effet catalyseur depuis la guerre en
Ukraine,
pour l'instant, la Russie avait réussi.
Alors certes à quel prix vis-à-vis de la
Chine parce que je pense que la Russie
est quand même perdante quand on voit
que la que la qu'ils abandonne une
partie du Caucas leur rival de toujours
qui est la Turquie que il on fait les
soldes on n'est jamais perdant. Ouais,
ils acceptent des échanges avec avec la
Oui. qu'ils acceptent des échanges avec
avec la avec la Russie qui avec la la
Chine qui sont quand même très
déstructuré.
Euh sur pour revenir à à cette question
là, le aujourd'hui oui, on est on est on
est doublement perdant. Euh déjà, on
aurait pas dû rouler des mécaniques et
dire qu'on a enfin c'était à l'époque le
mise est un pronom indéfini qui en
l'occurrence
définit donc la France et l'Europe sont
doublement perdantes. Euh le M c'est la
France. Oui, bah ça a été en tout cas le
mise de l'économie de la France et
lorsqu'il a dit qu'il mettrait les
l'économie euh russe genoux à terre, euh
il a il a il a il a commis une énorme
erreur que certains dénonçaient hein euh
j'en étais, hein, voilà, parce qu'il
fallait être plus humble et attendre les
la les résultats de tout cela. Donc le
effectivement, on voit très bien qu'on
rachète une partie du gaz russe via
l'Azerbaïdjan. C'est une réalité
peut-être aussi. peut-être Vial, oui, je
l'ai lu, avec la Turquie qui a qui a
pris un rôle pivot essentiel, hein, et
et Erdogan, je le dis, est un très
astucieux, très dur d'ailleurs, très
astucieux et on voit l'influence de la
Turquie, y compris en Afrique. On parle
souvent de l'influence russe au
détriment de l'influence française en
Afrique, mais l'influence turque est une
réalité, compris au Levant et y compris
au Levant, y compris au Levant
qui est un sujet majeur aussi
géopolitique.
On a donc laissé les Américains
amplifier leur leur main mise sur
beaucoup de domaines. Ils vont être face
à d'autres difficultés hein parce que
les États-Unis ont quand même le le
privilège exorbitant du dollar qui est
remise en cause de plus en plus. Euh
moi, j'attends de voir pour juger la
politique de de Donald Trump et je ne
lui porte pas griev
États-Unis ce qu'il pensait être les
intérêts des États-Unis. Mais est-ce que
à la fin, il défendra vraiment les
intérêts des États-Unis euh avec cette
façon euh brutale de de mettre les pieds
dans le platin euh de notamment de quand
il quand il parle le droit de douane, il
soulèvent au vrai des vrais sujets
d'autres contraintes tarifaires qu'on
veut pas regarder chez nous parce qu'on
est dans la moraline mais il soulèvent
des vrais problèmes. C'est quoi la
moraline ? La moraline c'est c'est quand
on on fait une espèce de leçon pleine de
de bienpensance et de moral. C'est un
terme, c'est Nietzsche qui parlait de
moraline. Euh Michel Onfré l'utilise
beaucoup et euh et faire culpabiliser
l'autre et pour faire culpabiliser
l'autre et ça évite tout euh toute
argumentation si vous voulez vous
dénigrer l'autre avec de la moraline et
puis il y a plus d'arguments quoi. Et
donc pour revenir à la question qui
était très intéressante, on a donc
aujourd'hui oui, on a régressé en en
croissance quand vous pensez que 55 %
des dividendes de des du 440 sont
profitent à l'étranger, qu'on qu'on
manque de de fonds d'investissement, que
nos ETI manquent de capitalisation, il y
a un vrai sujet et ça vient en
particulier de ce problème énergétique.
Mais ce qu'il faut mon avis anticiper
aussi puisqu'on parlait de prospective,
c'est la compétition sur les capitaux.
Il y a une une il va y avoir une
inflation une guerre d'accès aux
capitaux parce que on a des il y a eu le
le quoi qu'il en coûte qui chez nous a
été du n'importe quoi qu'il en coûte au
départ a été justifié mais il fallait
revenir et puis il a été prolongé pour
aller jusqu'à la présidentielle et
c'était la deuxième faute grave du
président. La première faute, ça a été
le nucléaire qui était pas une erreur
mais une faute. Et la deuxième faute
grave, ça a été de prolonger ces
dispositifs de socialisation de
l'économie et qui nous coûte très cher
et qui nous plante nos enfants et qui
nous plantent aujourd'hui. Donc il y a
et les États-Unis quand même ont
un privilège exorbitant du dollar qui va
être de plus en plus remis en cause, une
une un besoin de capitaux extrêmement
fort et avec en Europe quelques États
fragiles dont la France devient le plus
fragile. Pourquoi ? Parce qu'on cumule
déficit public très élevé et un déficit
commercial très élevé et un déficit
énergétique très élevé. Et et alors
on est devenu un nouveau exportateur
d'électricité mais on est déficitaire
net par les hydrocarbures. Une question
pour un champion ? Non parce que je
saurais pas répondre donc ça me les
intérêts de la dette convertis en baril
de pétrole journalier. Ça représente
bien. Alors les intérêts de la dette
converti je vais peut-être vous dire une
bêtise mais je
je pense que c'est le double en
équivalence de consommation en baril.
C'est ça. On doit être à 2000 à 100000
barra le sujet. Pardon ? Qui c'est qui
vous a fait travailler le sujet ? Euh je
sais plus. Je sais pas, on consomme
entre 1,3 et 1,6 million de baril par
jour en France. Tout confondu. OK. Et on
doit être au double en et les intérêts,
c'est pratiquement le double. Bon, je je
pas mal. Ouais. Il y a combien de zéro
en 1 milliard ?
Donc on continue des gars qu'on qu'on
garde depuis longtemps. OK. Donc il y a
0 1 milliard 8 non
euh 9. Toi, tu as pas le droit d'aider
toi.
Le revenons à nos moutons. Pardon. Notre
PIB, notre énergie. Oui. Non, mais sur
les capitaux, pardon, c'était dans nos
moutons. Sur quoi ? Une armée ou de
l'énergie. Non, non, mais la la compé,
il faut bien comprendre que on peut on
peut avoir aussi une bah pour l'instant
le le le l'euro n'est pas une monnaie
souveraine, c'est une monnaie sans
souverain. Donc, on une monnaie fantôme
peut-être aussi. Je sais pas mais c'est
je j'ai pas la qualification pour le
dire mais c'est en tout cas c'est une
monnaie sans souverain ce qui ce qui
pose un problème c'est comme un
souverain sans monnaie mais c'est un
autre sujet mais le enfin d'ailleurs
c'est lié mais il il va y avoir une
compétition sur les capitaux et on peut
avoir un vrai problème aux États-Unis je
pense qu'il faut qu'on le comprenne.
La Chine va avoir besoin de capitaux les
États-Unis vont avoir besoin de capitaux
donc la France a besoin de capitaux. On
va avoir on va on va lever on a en 2025
entre 300 340 milliards de capitaux en
France. Donc ça fait 345 plus 90 ça fait
beaucoup quand même. Et enfin avec 90
derrière et et donc là-dessus
les
les cette compétition va se traduire
comment ? Par une il faut parler en taux
d'intérêt réel, donc en inflation
réelle, en problème de de niveau de vie.
Les États-Unis vont peut-être qui va
vouloir encore acheter des obligations
américaines ? Est-ce que ça va pas
mettre en fragilité des actifs
américains qui seront peut-être moins
attractifs parce qu'il y aura moins de
fiabilité sur les propriétés qu'on
pourra avoir en actif américain ? Donc
ça veut dire que il faut les rendre plus
attractif donc d'évaluer le dollars.
Augmenter les taux mais ça risque d'être
exponentiel. Est-ce que Est-ce qu'on
peut donc ça ça peut on peut rentrer
dans dans des pardonnez-moi
pardonnez-moi dans des tourments
notamment par les capitaux et et donc on
en revient toujours à cette question
fondamentale.
La seule façon d'appréhender ces
tourbillons extérieur c'est d'être le
moins faible possible et le plus fort
possible à l'intérieur. Je vais vous
demander l'ubicuité et de faire une
expérience de pensée avec moi. C'est de
la quantique même ça. Ouais. On va faire
une crème vous et moi qu'on vendra à Can
au festival.
On fait une expérience de pensée là.
Vous m'avez dit les tourbillons, mais ça
c'est les tourbillons vu par les
Européens. Peut-être voir l'Afrique
aussi. Mais mettez-vous à la place de
l'Américain Trump. Oui. Il va dévaluer
son dollar. Oui, ce que je viens de vous
dire. Il va il va produire un max
d'énergie. H il est content. Il va
exporter taquet, il est content.
Nous les Européens, on va se retrouver
coincés avec une énergie cin fois plus
chère. Les capitaux qu'on détient au
dollar, bah ça va être dévalué. L'euro
est à combien par rapport au dollars au
jour ? On on est on n'est pas assez
éloigné dans le constat que de que je
vous dis hein. Est-ce qu'on essaie de se
mettre du côté américain ? Oui, mais
j'essaie justement de mettre du côté
américain et je veux pas tomber dans les
jum peremptoires. Donc je vous l'ai dit
tout à l'heure mais il y a quand même un
risque de de enfin il me semble que ce
que vous dites peut-être vrai mais que
les Américains ne sont pas les seuls à
produire de l'énergie.
Euh oui oui oui oui oui oui. Quelque
chose. Bah
non, il me semble que le le pays du golf
produisent de de l'énergie. Il me semble
que le l'Inde est devenue une plateforme
que la Chine va être de plus en plus a
produit un milliard de tonnes de charbon
l'année dernière. Que oui, il a ouvert
des centrales à charbon. Ils en
ouvraient deux par semaine l'année
dernière euh pendant que nous on faisait
des aid des feux. le le Ouais, je je
l'ai passé parce que c'est une réalité.
Euh le que la la Russie euh est un grand
producteur d'énergie, hein, très grand
producteur d'énergie. Euh donc non, il y
a pas que les États-Unis, mais tout cela
est vrai, mais il me semble que on est,
je crois qu'on est vraiment un
basculement,
mais des gens plus savants que moi,
pourraz vous le dire, c'est pas mon rôle
d'ailleurs, que on est à la fin du cycle
de la Renaissance. Donc on est à la fin
du cycle européen du monde. Les
États-Unis étaient finalement la
dernière expression de
l'Europénalisation du monde et que le le
fait que les États-Unis et l'Europe se
doivent rester alliés, moi j'ai toujours
pensé qu'il il devaient rester alliés,
qu'il y avait quelque chose à faire avec
l'Italie de ce point de vue-là tout de
suite. plus dangereux d'être de leurs
alliés. Mais oui oui, mais c'est oui
enfin oui enfin aujourd'hui les
États-Unis euh il représentent à eux
seuls je crois 37 % des dépenses
mondiales de défense. Donc je sais pas
quel est le plus dangereux des deux. Le
problème c'est la la fiabilité de la
parole des États-Unis.
Mais euh on passe d'un d'un système
européen à un système d'influence et
dans cette période de bouleversement, on
est à nouveau dans une confrontation de
zone d'influence et de rapport de force.
Là, nous, on raisonner en droit. Il faut
pas abandonner euh le raisonnement en
droit, mais nous sommes dans une période
où on doit à nouveau affirmer des
rapports de force. Et toute la question
étourdissante de du rôle de l'Europe, on
n'est pas allé jusqu'au bout tout à
l'heure d'ailleurs de de la capacité
dans cette dans ce monde multipolaire
dont on parle depuis des des années d'
défendre nos intérêts, de poser nos
intérêts, de poser nos alliances.
Comment arrivons-nous à recréer un axe
transatlantique ? Parce que vous savez,
même si aujourd'hui c'est la zone
pacifique qui est devenue le le centre
du nouveau monde où la France a beaucoup
d'arguments puisqu'on a la deuxième zone
d'expansion exclusive au monde hein
grâce à nos outre mè. Euh de mémoire on
n'est pas loin de 10 de kilomè carr
c'est c'est un atout euh ça il faut
savoir le regarder en face mais il faut
il faut savoir le protéger. Il faut il
faut savoir ce que ça implique derrière
en moyen militaire d'influence et
cetera. Mais euh donc la la le la
relation transatlantique, elle reste
quand même très importante parce que euh
on parlait du rôle des gars femmes, on
beaucoup de nos composantes y compris
dans euh moi j'ai pas le vocable mais
dans dans les dans les puces
électroniques dans sont aujourd'hui on
dépend de Taiïwan et des États-Unis dans
dans beaucoup de domaines. Donc il faut
faire quand même très attention à à ne à
ne pas saccager une relation qui est
aujourd'hui incontournable de toute
façon et savoir nous projeter à court
terme, moyen terme et long terme pour
être de plus en plus souverain et
indépendant visàvis de Est-ce qu'on peut
avoir une relation entre le suzerin et
le ser ?
Alors moi ma philosophie de vie qui
vient de mon expérience de du du petit
commerce c'est qu'il faut jamais être
ser quoi. Donc là on est serà
technologiquement parlant on a les gars
femmes avec la NSA qui nous ont ouvert
nos propres services. Notre armée est
dépendante le petit peuple est
dépendant. Ils ont la capacité de faire
du renseignement de terrain via la
collecte la collecte de data. En plus
nous on fait stocker nos datas chez eux.
chiffré, pas chiffré, avec de la ES256
ou pas de la ES256,
c'est quand même open bar.
Là, c'est on est un peu les sers
technologiquement, on est les sers
énergétiquement parlant.
On est les sers aussi des Chinois avec
les slips à 2 €. On est les sers des
Russes avec l'énergie pas chère qui nous
ils nous ont mis en en
comment dire ça d'une façon
diplomatique. Ils nous ont mis en
dépendance.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec l'Europe là ?
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? On a des Yaka
Faucons à Bruxelles. On a je vois que
j'ai envie que mais derrière ça a aucune
lecture, aucune moelle épinière en terme
des fondamentaux même de nos sociétés
thermoindustrielles sur un échiquier de
guerre économique hyper agressive. On a
oui oui planètes.
Ils nous font fermer des centrales
nucléaires. On va mettre l'économie
russe à genou. Il y a qu'à faucon, il y
a qu'à faucon et à côté de ça, on a des
gamins qui se font planter à coup de
couteau.
On fait quoi là dans le dur ? Non mais
vous enfin tout ce que vous dites,
pardonnez-moi, c'est c'est tout ce que
je dis hein et c'est pour ça que je
m'engage dans la dans la vie publique et
j'accepte d'être de ce côté de l'écran
si vous voulez. C'est parce que je tout
ce que vous dites me me m'indispose au
plus haut point, me me révolte et et
alors qu'on a le potentiel. Donc votre
question, elle est elleelle elle est
trop ouverte. Enfin, elle est très
ouverte. ce serait je laisse ouvrir les
portes. Elle est elle est très ouverte
parce que vous on parle du régalien,
l'attaque au couteau et cetera. Donc
j'ai j'essaie d'y répondre de depuis
tout à l'heure à tout cela. Un je je je
La France a tout à fait les moyens de
retrouver très vite une ambition
scientifique et culturelle et éducative.
Voilà comment on fait. Alors comment on
fait l'éducation ? de choses. D'abord,
il faut libérer l'instruction et
l'instruction publique, le tron commun
d'enseignement de de toutes les scories
d'idéologie quel qu'elle soit. Et
aujourd'hui, les idéologies sont des
idéologies. Moi, j'ose le terme
voquiste. Voilà, c'est une réalité. Je
disais à mon fils récemment, écoute, on
t'apprend à trier, mais on t'apprend pas
tellement à compter quoi. Donc je
préfère qu'on t'apprenne à compter.
Voilà. Pourquoi j'ai pas compris trier ?
Parce que il faut du truc sur les trious
les jours des déchets, ce qui est
important, mais enfin c'est assez facile
à comprendre et euh il y a pas de souci
là-dessus. Je pense que le rôle de
l'école, c'est d'instruire, d'instruire
sur et de rendre libre des individus.
C'est de les rendre libres par euh la
philosophie qui devrait être mise. Ça
vous paraît bizarre de commencer par ça
? Mais la raison critique, j'ai une tête
qui me paraît bizarre là. Je sais pas
parce que j'ai pas mis une tête, donc je
vous vois pas, je vous vois fou. Pouvez
mettre vos lunettes s'il vous plaît.
Mais mais donc c'est pas coqué. Non non
parce que là ça me fait un voile comme
ça je peux me concentrer. Et donc le le
donc pour revenir à ma question le
aujourd'hui dans le monde du 21e siècle
les gamins les plus performants seront
ceux qui seront décodés le monde plutôt
que coder l'informatique. Lil fera mieux
que nous. Donc un, je l'ai fait dans ma
commune de Cann sur le temps
périscolaire par la ville de Canne. On
propose aux enfants des cours de philo,
des cours de grec et de latin de la
maternelle jusqu'au CM2 puisque ce qu'on
maîtrise dans les écoles communales et
ça cartonne, ça marche, c'est tout le
temps plein. C'est c'est quelque chose
pour apprendre donc le français,
l'étymologie, la bonne maîtrise de la
langue et la l'argumentation,
accepter l'argument contraire, le le
retoquer, le remouliner et cetera. Donc
ça c'est essentiel refaire
l'apprentissage sur alors c'est devenu
tar à la crème dire les fondamentaux
mais sur mathématique
français euh raison critique évidemment
langue étrangère anglais et puis les
humanités l'après-midi, le sport et ça
c'est la base. Ensuite il faut
absolument libérer l'école.
l'école
au nom de un des plus gros gros
problèmes de notre pays, c'est
l'égalitarisme.
Tout tout ce qui me guide moi dans dans
mon projet, c'est de d'avoir une action
publique qui puisse faire en sorte qu'on
soit que la la France soit indépendante,
souveraine et qu'on puisse être donc
propriétaire de notre vie. Être
propriétaire de sa vie, c'est quoi ?
c'est avoir accès à du savoir, avoir
accès à des revenus, ne ne plus accepter
de voir des gens qui bossent et et qui
ont des revenus qui leur permettent à
peine de survivre. Il il y a il y a
vraiment c'est pas une vue de l'esprit,
c'est pas de la démagogie de dire qu'il
y a de plus en plus de travailleurs
pauvres. C'est c'est pas on est au 21e
siècle, c'est impensable. Bon, donc être
propriétaire de sa vie, il a combien de
français qui gagne 2200 balles par mois
ou du moins autour de 2200 balles ? Bah
c'est le le revenu médian 2200, ça fait
combien de pourcent ? Bah c'est le 50 %
donc puisque c'est le revenu médian.
Donc euh c'est pas le revenu moyen,
c'est le revenu médian, hein. Donc ça
veut dire que 50 % personne qui paye
l'impôt sur le revenu. L'impôt sur le
revenu aujourd'hui, malheure il il n'y
a, j'allais dire que 47 % des des
Français qui payent l'impôt sur le
revenu, même c'est même descendu à 46,5.
Ce qui signifie quand même que plus de
50 % des Français ne payent pas l'impôt
sur le revenu et vous avez 10 % des
Français qui payent 75 % de l'impôt sur
Monsieur Lisnard. Oui. Donc mais vous
j'apprécie votre raisonnement de
remettre les fondamentaux et de libéral
venir à l'essentiel libérer l'école
l'église au milieu du village. Oui, je
vais être très trivial si vous
m'autorisez mais vous vous me l'avez
reproché tout à l'heure donc et donc je
m'adapte donc ça fera un partout alors
ou attention
je je vais essayer de le faire d'une
façon très diplomatique.
J'apprécie ce raisonnement. H
je vais essayer de vous mettre en
condition. On est tous autour du feu.
Ouais. De nuit et on fait griller les
marchemallow. H à côté de vous, il y a
le petit-père espagnol. À à côté de
droit, il y a le petit-père allemand. Le
petit-père allemand qui aime bien avoir
les marshmallow des autres. Et il y a
toute l'Union européenne. Et là, il y a
un gros ours qui arrive. Un gros gros
ours.
Votre stratégie, c'est apprendre au
petits copains à faire ses lacet.
C'est quoi le Non, pardonnez-moi mais je
sais c'est peut-être diplomatique mais
je comprends même pas la métaphore parce
que je réponds à votre question sur
l'éducation l'ours là je veux bien sur
l'éducation mais c'est que vous pouvez
pas revenir une puissance si vous n'êtes
pas une puissance éducativeour
la stratégie c'est de faire tomber les
copains et de courir plus vite. Là il va
falloir il va falloir sauver le navire
là. Ben vous voyez la stratégie ce
serait vous d'avoir une arme automatique
à fort impact et de filer un fusil un
peu moins puissant à tous vos copains et
leur dire on tire dans la même direction
sur le gros ours. Voilà, c'est ce serait
ça. Et les gars tireront ça sera tir moi
ce serait la mienne, ça serait donc ils
tireront dans la même direction parce
qu'ils savent que si on tombe pas
d'accord, vous avez une arme automatique
un peu plus puissante. Donc aujourd'hui
la France a des avantages souverains.
L'avantage c'est notre siège au conseil
permanent de sécurité de l'ONU.
L'avantage c'est l'appareil. on a 290
ogives nucléaires. Euh donc il en faut
un peu plus. Euh l'avantage c'est tout
le complexe euh nucléaire qu'il faut
relancer à la fois civil et et euh et
militaire. Donc ces avantages-là
évidemment doivent redevenir des
priorités de l'action publique. Mais
parallèlement sur le travail éducatif
scientifique est fondamental et c'est
pas apprendre à faire ses lacers. C'est
pas apprendre à faire ses lasser que de
dire qu'on va former des scientifiques
et qu'on va les garder chez nous. Parce
que vous voyez les Mais c'est pour ça
qu'il faut c'est comme dans une boîte.
Moi je je ne connais que les
raisonnements entrepreneurux, c'estd que
vous avez des résultats à court terme,
vous avez des résultats à moyen terme,
des résultats à long terme. Et moi qui
vient du commerce,
je me souviens voilà nous dans le
commerce le matin, le court terme, on
ouvrait la boutique, le moyen terme, on
prenait les sandwich à midi, le long
terme, on faisait la caisse. Bon, dans
un état, c'est un peu plus compliqué, le
long terme est un peu plus long. Mais
donc, c'est pas apprendre à faire ces
lasser, c'est pas du tout secondaire.
Voyez comment des États aujourd'hui
arrivent à s'en sortir de la
compétition. Je pense aux Émirats arabes
unis parce que ils investissent
énormément sur la science. Déjà à Dubaï
? Euh oui, je suis déjà à Doub. Quelle
est leur vision
Dubaï ? C'est Abu Dhabi. He merci.
Quelle est leur vision ? Quelle est leur
vision du système éducatif ? Alors, je
connais mieux les Émirats arabes unis
que Dubaï. Euh Dubaï est plus sur le
tourisme et les fin la finance. Mais les
Émirats arabes unis, quand vous regardez
ce qu'ils font, c'est qu'ils ont dans
une phrase hein niveau éduc ben c'est
l'exigence, c'est c'est la performance
et et c'est et et ensuite euh c'est la
discipline. Enfin, moi je le sais
puisque j'ai mes amis des amis qui sont
installés là-bas pour ça justement pour
le le le le le le la la la performance
et c'est le le le le travail,
l'exigence, la comparaison et la et on
met en confiance les gamins. Ils les
mettent en confiance comme en Finlande
on met en confiance les gamins. Le
système éducatif de Finlande marche
beaucoup mieux que le nôtre. Et ensuite,
il faut de l'émulation entre
établissements. Le problème de la
France, c'est qu'on au nom de
l'égalitarisme, on a euh on a assigné à
résidence identitaire et sociale des
dizaines de milliers de gamins, c'est
que les plus pauvres, les gamins des
immigrés pauvres et cetera. Je le vois,
on les met dans des écoles qui sont des
ghetto avec des profs qui sont moins
aguéris. Revenons à la ceinture
Percique. Leur vision du système
éducatif, c'est un doit-on faire un
système éducatif pour comme designer
pour une usine, c'est-à-dire former des
gamins pour le business derrière ou
doit-on avoir un système éducatif pour
apprendre à penser ? C'est leur vision.
Vous vous êtes plutôt de quel côté ? On
apprend à penser ou on forme des gamins
pour servir l'intérêt du business ? Je
vois pas la j'ai jamais vu la
contradiction entre les deux. J'ai
jamais vu la contradiction entre les
deux. Euh là aujourd'hui, on a
d'abord, il faut apprendre à penser,
c'est la base de tout. Et là la raison
enfin toutes les les boîtes aujourd'hui
cherchent des des des talents qui savent
penser toutes. Donc c'est là où je vois
pas la contradiction. C'est qui recrute
de puissance de deuxièmement. Oui
certainement. Oui, bien sûr, parce que
ça crée du conformisme. Il y a rien de
pire que le conformisme. Le conformisme,
ça crée du révolutionnisme. C'est c'est
les deux conformisme, c'est c'est c'est
le le le mauvais glissement de de notre
système. Et mais parallèlement juste il
y a dans les entreprises, on a aussi de
de besoins de fonction plus
spécialisées. C'est pour ça le système
éducatif, il est pas monolithique, il
faut plus qu'il soit monolitique. Et il
y a deux formes d'intelligence. Il y a
une intelligence déductive. C'est une
intelligence qui part du concept, qui
part et qui va vers la matière. C'est
celle du collège unique. C'est celle
qu'on a développé en France et qui et et
qui qui est pertinente, hein. Mais il y
a aussi une intelligence inductive qui
part du rapport à la matière et qui part
vers le concept. Et c'est celle qu'on a
développé dans l'apprentissage euh
notamment. Bon et ben ça euh ce que je
veux dire c'est que les formes
d'excellence euh je le débat entre il
faut apprendre à penser, moi je l'ai
entendu plein de fois, il est
intéressant mais le le le l'entreprise a
aussi un rôle ensuite de formation.
C'est c'est son job aussi. Mais pour
avoir été des deux côtés de la barrière,
euh avoir été recruté, avoir été
recruteur, euh vous avez des métiers
très spécialisés. Or certains vous
voulez pas perdre de temps, il faut tout
de suite des personnes opérationnelles,
d'où la nécessité d'avoir des entités de
formation qui vous produisent des gens
performants et cetera, mais vous
cherchez très souvent des gens qui
savent réfléchir et le 21e siècle, il
sera de plus en plus là-dedans pour
utiliser tous les outils qui sont les
notes, les outils de la robotique, des
nanotechnologies, de l'intelligence
artificielle. C'est pas une vue de
l'esprit, c'est pas abstrait. Un
agriculteur, il réfléchit beaucoup. Un
agriculteur, il il réagit, il il
raisonne aujourd'hui de façon holistique
globale, mais il aussi il a une
expérience extrêmement concrète. C'est
c'est vrai dans dans tous les métiers de
production parce qu'il a une expérience
concrète qu'il est capable de réfléchir
à 360°. Non. Oui. Oui. Je crois. Et
c'est ce qui fait d'ailleurs que moi
j'ai j'ai voulu être maire parce que je
trouve que c'est un mandat de praticien.
C'estd que vous à la fois vous sourcez
toute la journée, vous enfin vous
essayez de vous documenter, de voir les
évolutions 2014 2014. Et avant j'ai été
élu enfin adjointommer 2001 et et mais
ensuite parce que c'est un mandat vous
pouvez pas procrastiner. Ça ressemble
beaucoup à ce que j'ai vécu en PME, vous
prenez des décisions, vous devez
arbitrer, vous vous avez parfois des
décisions, vous tâtonnez hein, vous avez
des échissnard,
pardon. Combien ça dure une réunion avec
David Lissard ? Euh, à mes yeux toujours
trop longtemps, mais aux yeux de ceux
qui bossent avec moi, ils trouvent que
c'est trop court, très souvent com ça
fait. Non, je peux pas vous le dire.
J'essaie de les formater minutes. Non
non, je vais pas être Alors, il y a des
réunions qui durent 10 minutes. Les
réunions qui durent des minutes, ce sont
des réunions où j'ai déjà eu ma j'ai
confronté les points de vue et où
j'arrive en en donnant des instructions
en en en écoutant le retour qu'on me dit
sur la capacité d'exécution. Cel peuvent
durer 10 minutes. Mais autrement des il
y a des réunions où je me laisse exposer
des choses et je veux pas formater ça.
Alors j'ai vu ça en moi j'ai vécu ça en
boîte. J'ai trouvé ça très pas trop
forcément performant mais j'essayie de
faire en sorte que ça tienne moins d'une
heure. Donc c'est moins long qu'une
interview ici. Donc là ça c'est juste un
apéritif
avec ce qui vous attend.
Donc là on a appris à faire ses laassés.
OK.
Revenons à notre métaphore de l'ours qui
est en train de nous attraper là. H on
fait quoi ? On monte les dents, on fait
des crocheptes à nos copains pour qu'il
dévorent nos petits copains et pour nous
gagner
laisser gagner du temps. On fait quoi
pour montrer les dents ? Mais pour
montrer les dents, on aura toujours des
dents moins grosses que l'ours. Donc ça
veut dire que euh là-dessus, on un on
définit nos pour quitter la métaphore,
on va pas la quitter parce que les
Allemands nous ont fait des crocheptes.
Non mais c'est pas de la métaphore ça.
C'estd que les Allemands, j'ai même
écrit des papiers là-dessus, nous ont
planté sur l'industrie de l'armement
mais de historiquement de tout temps et
nous ont planté sur l'énergie, hein.
Donc ils ont mais mais mais les
Allemands nous ont planté, c'est notre
faiblesse le responsable. Le problème
c'est quand on a accepté et et la vision
ultime de ça c'est lorsque le président
de la République justifie la fermeture
de Fessenheim. C'est pas vieux hein. Il
fait un revirement incroyable
au moment de la présidentielle mais il
justifie la deuxième présidentielle la
fermeture de Fenheim en disant oui parce
qu'on était proche de l'Allemagne. Vous
vous souvenez ça a été dit comme alors
que parallèlement à Paris vous pouvez
recevoir des particules fines lorsque le
vent dest souffle qui viennent
d'Allemagne qui avait rouvert des ches
centrales à charbon. l'Allemagne qui se
mettait en dépendance au gaz russes et
qui ont donc entretenu une ambiguïé
stratégique vis-à-vis de l'Ukraine
pendant trop longtemps euh parce que
dépendante du gaz russe. C'est pour ça
qu'on a fait sauter Norstream. Donc euh
ça j'ai pas assez d'informations mais
c'est je oui c'est c'est en tout cas
c'est une c'est une des explications
plausibles. C'était pour les décider. Je
sais pas je sais pas mais c'est c'est
plausible. C'est c'est plausible. Bon le
donc euh d'autres de plausible ? Il y a
plein de choses de plausible. Mais sur
quel sujet ? sur le la guerre, qu'est-ce
qu'il y a de plausible ? Je comprends
pas la question.
Comment vous posez la question ? On voit
Norstream qui pète. Hm. À votre avis, ça
vient des Ukrainiens, des Russes, des
Européens ou des Américains ? Je sais
pas. Je je je crois avoir entendu
récemment que les États-Unis étaient
potentiellement
potentiellement dirigé l'opération.
Voilà. Mais je c'est pas moi. Quels sont
les objectifs de faire péter Nurstream ?
c'est peut-être
de
bah de renvoyer vers tout simplement la
dépendance énergétique américaine quoi.
Ça pourrait être un objectif tout
simplement voilà de flinguer l'économie
allemande ou de la rendre dépendante.
Euh alors, on va voir ce qui se passe
avec le nouveau chancelier mais euh
celui qui qui a l'air très euh véhément,
on verra dans dans 1000 milliards de
réarmement. Ouais. 40 % de son PIB. Oui,
il faut il faut il faut il faut que ça
donne une Allemagne réarmée avec parfois
les les gens font ce qu'ils disent. Donc
il faut il faut pas négliger, il faut
faut C'est très bien. Ça nous changera
de Macron. Il faut pas sous-estimer
cela, mais ça nécessite La France a
perdu une opportunité phénoménale de
reprendre un lead en Europe au moment de
la guerre en Ukraine. C'est que si on
avait pas fait n'importe quoi sur le
plan énergétique,
on avait la capacité, on aurait dû en
2023 discuter de la répartition de nos
excédents de nos des dividendes de DF
pour résumer à l'extrême de nos
excédents énergétiques.
On a discuté de l'effondrement du cours
de de et et de des pertes financières de
DF parce que par notre faute, enfin
notre faute, la faute des nos
dirigeants,
nous avons cédé aux injonctions
allemandes sur le mix énergétique
européen, donc d'investir sans faire une
analyse coût avantage sur le le
renouvelable et la fermeture de Fenheim
et une loi de programmation qui est
prévoyée
en la revendiquant 14 fermetures de
réacteur nucléaires. C'était c'est pas
une lucidité rétrospective de ma part.
J'ai écrit à l'époque papier qui avait
agacé beaucoup mais je le je agacé qui ?
Le président de la République qui a
agacé ses anciens premier ministres. Bon
les téléphoné non mais vous savez qu'il
a été agacé parce que il nous a arrivé
d'échanger et parce que certains ses
collaborateurs étaient missionnés pour
me parler aussi. C'était des des potes,
des gens que je connais depuis
longtemps. Alex Coler. Non non non non,
je connais enfin je connais, je l'ai
croisé mais je connais pas. C'est c'est
pas mon mon univers le donc euh
là-dessus, on a loupé cette cette
échéance. On a à nouveau une opportunité
aujourd'hui, c'est certain, puisque
puissance nucléaire militaire et civile.
Mais la difficulté, c'est que lorsque
vos intérêts de la dette vont être
supérieurs à votre budget militaire,
vous avez des difficultés pour être
crédibles. l'éducation nationale. On va
passer aujourd'hui donc en 2024 les
seuls intérêts de la seule dette du seul
état, donc ce qu'on a payé avec nos
impôts en intérêt de de la dette de
l'État a représenté cinq fois le budget
de la justice. On manque cruellement de
place de prison, de greffiers, de
magistrat en de policiers, tout ça. Cinq
fois le budget du seul ministère de la
justice.
Et on va donc puisque c'était plus de 55
milliards, on va passer on va dépenser
plus en intérêt que l'éducation qui est
une des armes essentielles au 21e siècle
et on va à ce rythme là dépenser plus
que de 100 milliards d'euros d'intérêt
de la dette.
Donc comment si vous voulez la la
difficulté et l'enjeu c'est d'arriver à
être à nouveau dans une matrice de
prospérité qui nous permet de sortir de
cette phase descendante de la courbe de
l'affaire qui fait qu'on paye toujours
plus d'impôts et de prélèvement mais
qu'on s'apauvrit évidemment et qu'on a
de moins en moins d'infirmiers de
policiers tout en ayant le record du
monde de la dépense publique. Présenter
ça d'une façon différente. Si,
certainement mais expliquez-moi avec
d'autres mots. On on accable la
population qui travaille d'impôt pour
maintenir le train de vie de l'État et
maintenir l'illusion et le vernis. H
donc en gros en gros ceux qui bossent
se font tondre. Oui, pour faire semblant
auprès peut-être des agences de notation
ou auprès d'autres que on a toujours le
le le la barre de notre destinée entre
les mains. H On va où quand on a un
sevrage énergétique derrière imposer une
décroissance pas heureuse ? Ça va ça va
vers quoi ? La décroissance est rarement
heureuse déjà hein. Comment la
décroissance est rarement heureuse ?
Ouais, il faudra expliquer ça à quelques
gens d'autres gouvernement qui veulent
nous la sobriété heureuse, c'est comment
il ils avaient formulé ça ? Je mais euh
mais surtout enfin il y a là aussi
plusieurs plusieurs sujets. Donc le le
euh le le le problème c'est que on bride
de plus en plus le moteur et on veut
faire monter le moteur de plus en plus
vite quoi. Donc on est dans une
contradiction fondamentale avec une
calandre de dépenses publique qui est de
plus en plus lourde. Vous allez
travailler dans l'automobile ? Non mais
j'adore ça. Qu'est-ce qui se passe quand
on met trop d'air dans un carbu ? Bah ça
ça explose.
Voilà.
C'est l'oxygène et c'est une réaction
chimique assez simple tant que ça
explose. Donc c'est un moteur explosion
mais il faut que l'explosion soit au bon
niveau. Donc le on peut basculer du côté
de la violence et je l'avais dit
d'ailleurs en préambule comme et c'est
ce qu'il faut chercher à éviter
mais parallèlement il faut pas chercher
à étouffer la violence par la dépense
publique. Donc c'est là que on se doit
d'avoir une une alternative qui soit
puissante et qui passe forcément par un
changement d'approche de notre politique
publique. Le le la alors de façon pour
le dire autrement euh aujourd'hui
quelqu'un qui qui gagne 3000 € net donc
qui fait partie des riches selon
François Hollande qui gagne 3000 moi
combien je gagne ? se déclaré je vais
vous le dire. Non mais je vous le dire
hein, mais c'est en ligne, je dois être
en brut imposable à 90000 € par an. Et
donc par mois, ce qui nous fait 7000 et
des patates en brut imposable. 7000.
Ouais voilà. Ouais c'est ça. Ça doit
être 6000 et quelques ou 7000 mais
chacun peut vérifier puisque la
transparence fait que c'est tout est
tout est contrôlable. Donc euh le donc
quelqu'un qui aujourd'hui gagne 3000 €
net ou 3500 € net, je pour toucher ces
3500 € net un avant hier hein, net net,
il faut générer quasiment le double de
valeur ajoutée, hein. C'est ce que c'est
ce que j'évoqué tout à l'heure entre la
différence entre le super brut et et le
net. Et c'est cette différence qui est
le record du monde en France. Qu'est-ce
qu'il y a entre les deux ? Il y a les
prélèvements donc les impôts et et les
charges et donc qui incite soit se
barrer à l'étranger et les impôts ou les
cotisations. Oui, impôt et charges.
Quand je dis charges, je comprends
pardon les cotisations. Quand je dis les
charges, c'est les charges patronales,
les charges salariales, enfin toutes les
cotisations sur la valeur ajoutée. Et et
donc le le le si on veut augmenter le
salaire net, inciter les gens à bosser,
réduire le coût, c'està-dire améliorer
la compétitivité de nos entreprises, la
capacité de gagner des parts de marché
et de créer de la richesse, il faut
absolument ce qui d'éliore ce que ce
qu'il y a entre les deux. Ce qui est
entre les deux, ce sont des cotisations,
des charges, des impôts qui alimentent
un système de dépenses. Et c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui la baisse de la dépense,
elle est devenue incontournable. C'est
pas une fin en soi. Il y a des dépenses
productives. Euh et les technocrates,
soit ils vous font soit c'est du laxisme
et de façon condescendante vous disent
on distribue la la véroterie, donc on
vous fait une aide publique alors que on
est dans le rouge pour subventionner la
réparation des vêtements, les retouches
des vêtements ou des chaussures parce
que ça existe quand même aujourd'hui ce
trucl. Bon ou et et on va étendre le le
périmètre de l'action publique. Soit
tout d'un coup on va s'exciter et on va
faire du rabot et de l'impôt qui est le
degré zéro de la bonne gestion. Il faut
un peu de rabot, il faut parfois de
l'impôt. Mais dans une dans une boîte,
dans une entreprise, si vous mettez pas
du sensomission, si vous mettez pas de
la perspective de développement, si vous
ne cherchez pas ce qui est productif, ce
qui n'est pas productif,
je je le vois moi en collectivité,
l'État prélève la capacité
d'autofinancement
et et réduit la capacité
d'investissement, ce qui est
complètement absurde, ce qui est débile,
ce qui vraiment stupide là. Donc l'enjeu
aujourd'hui, il est de baisser ce qui ce
qui correspond à des dépenses de
fonctionnement, des dépenses de TR sur
quel électorat pour voter pour vous ? Je
moi je vise sur les Français qui tous
les Français qui ont envie que la France
s'en sorte. Je veux pas segmenter ça.
Quand on dit que vous faites partie du
camp des afouéristes. Ouais.
Vous avez une tronçonneuse.
Oui, c'est de la métaphore tout ça. Moi
ce truc là, je le dis. Alors, je
c'est aux gens de le dire, c'est pas à
moi de le dire. Moi ce que je vous dis,
c'est qu'on a fait un avec on a bossé
sur une réduction qui me paraît très
raisonnable, qui est qui est sourcée et
qui permet de recréer un effet vertueux
à terme. Il faut il faut des moyens dans
le service public. Vous êtes miop ? Oui.
Je vous disais combien ? Alors, on a
fait un plan sur 200 milliards, mais mon
objectif, ce que j'aimerais combien de
chacil, pardon ? Miop à combien de
chacœueil ? Je sais pas, je je sais pas
c'est le talbo qui le sait le parce que
comme je j'ai je Combien de temps pour
déboucher ?
C'est c'est alors c'est moins que le
dermato puisque la dernière fois il m'a
fallu 8 mois pour avoir un rendez-vous
chez le dermato qui est formidable. Ceci
étant et l'optalmou la dernière fois non
c'était pas non c'était pas si long
c'était 2 mois mais maintenant vous
savez qu'on peut aller chez l'opticien
direct donc je vais chez l'htalmo une
fois tous les 10 ans et chez l'opticien
une fois tous les ans. Donc une fois
cette parenthèse fermée euh la
vous fait des contenès. C'est une
technique de 200 Oui, j'ai bien compris
200 milliards. Donc et je vous transmis
200 milliards. Oui.
Puisqu'on a le temps ici de parler,
le ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que ce
qui compte c'est à la fin c'est un
pourcentage de la richesse produite.
Donc c'est là où il faut être comptable
mais où la comptabilité n'est qu'un
moyen. Et j'adore les comptables. J'en
ai dans mon équipe. J'ai mon parin que
j'adore qui expert comptable comptable
aussi. Mais les experts comptables
formidables et commissairire compte.
Commissai au compte. et on aurait dû
avoir plus d'experts comptables pour
ceux qui géraent l'État. Mais que
diriger une entreprise, c'est pas faire
que de la comptabilité, c'est aussi
faire du commerce, c'est aussi créer des
flux. C'est donner la cap et créer des
flux. C'est créer des flux. Tout est là.
Donc puisqu'on a le temps ici,
le ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que le
problème c'est pas la dépense publique
en elle-même, c'est l'excès de dépenses
publique par rapport à la richesse et
qu'aujourd'hui cet excès de dépense lui
est arrivé à un seuil où il nuit à la
création de richesse. C'est-à-dire que
cet excès de dépense pèse tel d'abord
enlève des gens du marché du travail
puisqu'il dissuade de travailler par un
système qui incite à l'oisiveté. Donc
vous avez des un système qui incite à
l'ovasiveté qui flatte des des
électorats électorats retraités,
électorat d'assugujetti sociaux et
derrière des réalités sociales aussi
humaines très difficiles. OK ? Donc
c'est toujours délicat de parler de ça.
Deuxième élément, vous avez donc ce
système qui
vous pousse à loisiveter mais qui en
plus ne vous pousse pas à travailler.
C'estàd que c'est c'est un double effet
négatif puisque vous êtes en France plus
vous cotisez plus qu'ailleurs,
hein. Nous sommes les gens puisque le
système social c'est la dépense publique
sociale c'est 900 milliards d'euros. On
va atteindre les 900 milliards d'euros.
C'est presque un/ers de la richesse
produite. Donc il faut d'abord regarder
ce grand volant là. Sur 1000 € d'impôt,
ça représente combien la santé et les
retraites ? La santé et les alors
d'impôts ou de cotisation ? Parce que
c'est surtout sur les cotisations que
vous les retrouvez. C'est pas sur les
impôts, hein, pardonnez-moi, mais c'est
c'est surtout sur les cotisations. Vous
maîtrisez un peu le sujet ? Non non mais
c'est c'est il y a il y a une alors il y
a une malheureusement enfin
malheureusement ce qu'on nous cache
c'est que une partie des impôts vont sur
la retraite. Officiellement 54 milliards
d'euros mais en réalité plus
officieusement mais officieusement il y
a toute la la retraite hors bilan
c'est-à-dire celle qui n'est pas
financée et la retraite des
fonctionnaires. Donc c'est et mais je si
si je parce que vous me demandiez sur
les 200 milliards et euh donc alors
c'est pareil parce que quand je dis 200
milliards soit soit alors la jeune mais
enfin c'est infaisable, on trouve même
pas 40 milliards d'économies
quand confond avec des prélèvements
supplémentaires hein dans le langage
techno. 40 milliards d'économie c'est 40
milliards très souvent de prélèvement en
plus c'est pas des économies. C'est pour
ça qu'on me dit mais alors vous voulez
pas des économies pour les collectivités
? Si il y a pas de problème économie
mais proposez-moi des économies si vous
voulez qu'on parle collectivement on en
parlera aussi mais pour l'instant ce
qu'on propose c'est des prélèvements de
l'état sur les excédents que j'arrive à
faire. Bon le donc 200 milliards
justement mes fameuses lunettes 200
milliards 200 milliards de baisses vous
rendez compte que c'est ça sera nous
remettrait en dép en niveau des dépenses
publiques au niveau de l'Italie qui est
le pays qui dépense le plus après nous
hein c'est-à-dire que on est quasiment à
30 milli un point de PIB de richesse
produite c'est quasiment 30 milliards
d'euros 3 x 7 21 et on est à 7 donc on
est à 7 un point de plus donc on serait
les donc les objectifs
ce serait de de pourquoi pas d'aller au
niveau aller de faire un peu mieux
d'aller au niveau du Danemark si on
allait au niveau du Danemark il faudrait
baisser la dépense de 330 milliards
donc mon objectif secret ce serait là
mais si on allait au niveau de la Suisse
ou au pire mieux au niveau de l'Irlande
vous voyez les différentiels. Donc ce
n'est absolument pas délirant de dire
que sur un premier quinquena, on doit et
on peut baisser de 200 milliards la
dépense par an à la fin en dépense
annuelle toute chose est égale par
ailleurs pour arriver à moins de 50 % de
déficit de défense publique par rapport
au PIB. Je bon et mais qu'ensuite le but
c'est d'avoir de créer une spirale
vertueuse de la prospérité de la
création de richesse qui nous permettent
avec moins d'impôts d'avoir plus de
rentrée, c'est-à-dire d'avoir
d'augmenter le volume du moteur,
d'augmenter la puissance, la production
et donc d'avoir une capacité d'avoir nos
ambitions militaires
éducative et cetera. Vous avez étudié
Ricardo ? Étudier enfin je Oui.
Avantages comparatifs. Oui. Pourquoi
vous comparez des économies qui ne se
ressemblent pas ?
Parce que ça me paraît pas incompatible
parce que la une des clés me semble-t-il
de la richesse l'Irlande le pardon ils
font leur pognon avec quoi l'Irlande ?
Bah, il faut aujourd'hui avec les gars
femmes vert et et de l'évasion fiscale
euh c'est pas de l'évasion fiscale avec
euh de la performance fiscale. Mais vous
avez remarqué que l'objectif que je
donnais c'était pas l'Irlande. J'ai dit
je pourrais imaginer que mais c'est le
Danemark, ils sont quoi comme fond
souverain ? Mais le Oui, mais la Norvège
tiens, on pourra en parler la Norvège
encore mieux. Bah oui, ils ont ils ont
quand même une puissance aujourd'hui des
investissement. C'est ça, je sais plus.
Mais aujourd'hui euh puisqu'il se tire
la bour avec celui des Émirats arabes
unis, euh
ils sont devant en valeur absolue, mais
l'année dernière en investissement
c'était les arbres qui étaient devant le
la Norvège. Bon, enfin bref, le je
comprends pas bien la question parce que
la la richesse des nations, elle vient
précisément des avantages comparatifs.
Donc la France a d'autres avantages
comparatifs, mais si on veut être en
compétition avec ces pays-là, on en
revient ce que il faut la rentabilité du
capital, la rentabilité relative du
capital en comparaison doit être au
rendez-vous et ce on c'est là qu'on doit
travailler sur les facteurs de
production. Et comment on fait pour
produire ? Comment on fait pour se
réindustrialiser
sans énergie bon marché ? Non mais il
faut une énergie bon marché. Voilà. Il
faut la mar le papier le chocolat il
faut il y a c'est un objectif
stratégique. Ah mais et autant il y a
des choses qui sont peut-être
difficilement atteignables, autant
l'énergie bon l'énergie électrique bon
marché est tout à fait à à à porté de la
France. Donc on sort du marché de
l'électricité, on arrête d'indexer le
prix de l'électricité sur le gaz. On Ah
mais ça de toute façon on va en sortir
et ça et et ça c'est une aberration.
Donc euh c'est donc on est je pense
qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde est
d'accord là-dessus. On se et et c'est
moi, vous savez, j'ai toujours il y a il
y a un principe parce que tout à l'heure
c'est marrant, vous avez retenu l'IRO,
vous avez pas retenu le Danemark, vous
n'z et vous n'avez pas retenu les
Pays-Bas, vous n'avez pas retenu la
Suisse. Il y a des choses à regarder ce
qui se font envahit les Pays-Bas,
pardon. Quand est-ce qu'on envahit les
Pays-Bas ? Luxembourg. Non, non, moi je
pour la Suisse, ça va être plus
compliqué. Ça va être plus compliqué.
une réserve nationale puissante. Mais
là pour revenir à donc aujourd'hui la
France a les moyens, on est en
surproduction énergétique si on sort de
la doxa européenne mais qu'on raisonne
sur des accords européens, c'est-à-dire
par notre capacité d'exportation
électrique de refaire un accord sérieux
avec l'Italie qui a un accès au marché
algérien avec qui on est en froid, ça ne
vous a pas échappé de de de
retravailler, de refaire une une
démarche équilibré que l'Allemagne de
dire écoutez euh maintenant vous voulez
l'énergie décarbonée abandonnant de vos
marchés vous et bien on est en mesure de
vous exporter une partie une plus grande
quantité d'électricité mais il va
falloir qu'on revoie nos accords sur
l'armement notamment sur la technologie
y compris pour équiper des avions
des avions de défense donc c'est là où
on en revient c'est là où Ricardo la loi
des avantages comparatifs elle est tout
à fait pertinente avec des économies
différentes puisque c'est précisément de
cette différence d'économie qu'on a des
avantages compar comparative qui nous
permett de faire la richesse des
nations. C'est c'est toute la base de la
théorie de Ricardo. Après moi je suis
pas un théoricien, je suis un praticien
mais la je trouve qu'elle n'a jamais été
dépassé cette théorie. Alors théoricien,
on partage la dissuasion nucléaire avec
les Allemands, les Polonais.
Tout dépend de ce que vous appelez
partager. C'est-à-dire que il y a un
élément essentiel, c'est de Non, d'abord
moi je partage enfin partage jeis dire
un truc qui va être brutal. C'est dire
que je peux la louer ou la vendre. Mais
non, mais c'est-à-dire que un notre
siège au conseil permanent de l'ONU ne
peut appartenir qu'à la France.
C'est un des grands derniers avantages
que l'on doit une fois de plus au
général de Gaul. Ça, il faut le il faut
le garder précieux précieusement.
qu'ensuite on on se pose la question de
la place de l'Afrique et de l'Asie dans
ce conseil permanent, ça c'est une vraie
question. Revenons sur la diffusion
nucléaire, on ira faire un tour sur
l'Afrique qui un peu donc un je ne
partage pas ce siège. Voilà hein. Et
c'est déjà au conseil permanent de de
l'ONU de sécurité de l'ONU de sur la
le bouclier nucléaire le parapluie le le
le ou parapluie nucléaire il est
impensable brê aujourd'hui
le parasol d'avoir
une crédibilité dans une offre de
protection avec 290 au giv nucléaires.
Oui. Alors, les vecteurs de notre nos
290 OGIF, c'est quoi ? Ben, on a on a
trois outils de de de le rafal. Bon, il
s'est fait latter par un avion chinois
en Inde, donc oui, enfin c'est en train
d'être analysé. Il faut là pour le coup,
c'est un peu trivial là. Ouais. Non, il
s'est fait later. C'est c'est pas
démontré encore. D'accord. OK. Pas
démontré. C'est des cétait on vend des
rafales encore. Donc c'était des
supporters anglais. Donc il nous reste
quoi d'autre ? Mais on a nos sous-marins
nucléaires. OK. qui ont quoi comme
vecteur ? Et on a la la la toute la
force aéroportée, mais euh le le vecteur
bah c'est les c'est M51. M51. Est-ce que
les M51 sont toujours d'actualité, même
s'ils vont à 11000 km/h, est-ce que les
Russes ou les Chinois n'ont pas déjà les
capacités soit d'empêcher que ça
décolle, soit les intercepter en l'air ?
Il y a la réponse est dans votre
question. On sait désormais qu'il y a
une capacité de de cyber blocage, enfin
en tout cas on on pressend qu'il y a une
capacité de cyber blocage sur la M51.
Euh et mais vous savez qu'on a la
recherche de un programme de recherche
qui devrait nous nous faire sortir de
cet impasse. Enfin, d'après ce que j'ai
compris et d'après ce qu'on m'a dit. Et
deuxièmement, euh de toute façon, on
doit passer à un autre véhicule beaucoup
plus rapide et et beaucoup mieux protégé
sur le plan cyber. Les programmes sont
en cours, hein. Les programmes sont en
cours en la matière. Mais on a combien
de temps avant que on puisse dire à
Poutine si Jing Ping ou à Trump bon
maintenant on va arrêter les conneries
parce que là j'ai l'impression dans
votre constat il y a un trou d'air. Mais
mais parce que je suis réaliste.
Mais parce que je suis réaliste. Parce
que aujourd'hui autrement à moin que
vous vouliez faire du Emmanuel Macron,
c'est-à-dire faire un discours
performatif, c'est rouler des envie de
m'énerver. Oui. Faire donc ça réussi.
Non mais faire c'est rouler des
mécaniques en disant "Écoutez les gars,
on arrive et on on va protéger la
Pologne, on va faire un accord avec
l'Allemagne et et mais mais c'est
aujourd'hui impensable." C'est-à-dire
que et c'est là qu'il que la on est
obligé de reposer une stratégie qui va
avec des objectifs à 2 ans, 5 ans et à
10 ans. Mais ce serait complètement
irréaliste. C'est pour ça que je je dis
qu'il faut être très prudent dans nos
relations transatlantiques. Ça veut pas
dire baisser le froc, hein. Baisser le
froc, c'est rouler des mécaniques et
puis par derrière ensuite demander
pardon. Ça c'est baisser le fr.
Qu'est-ce qu'il disait maître Verges par
rapport à la France et les États-Unis ?
Pourtant le salot lumineux comme il
s'autoproclamait. Je je ne sais pas. Je
ne sais plus. Enfin, je sais pas
d'ailleurs. C'est pas Je sais plus.
Pourtant disais qu'on était devenu la
[__] des Américains. Oui. Oui. C'est
une formule à la mettre Vergesse. Ouais.
Euh mais c'est certains à l'époque
étaient la [__] du Vietmin he ou du
Vietkong.
Voilà. Euh certains étaient la [__] de
de la de de l'Union sovié de Oui,
certains étaient aussi la [__] de
l'Union soviétique. Voilà. Donc euh
qui être [__] je préfère ne pas être
[__] moi, l'Union soviétique et du
Vietkong en terme en terme en terme,
vous savez, en terme de renseignement,
les [__] c'est pas mal. Ouais. Euh
euh juste un détail, en terme de
renseignement et de prospective, je vous
je vous entendais tout à l'heure, bah on
n pas vu c, on n pas vu ça, on n pas
anticipé c, on n pas anticipé ça.
Comment ça se fait ? parce que on est
parti avec des gens qui savaient pas
faire leur laasset, des gens très
conformistes, des gens très intoxiqués,
des gens qui avaient leur propre
idéologie.
On fait quoi président David Lisnard
avec nos prospectivistes pour qu'ils
arrêtent de ressembler à des astrologues
? On fait quoi avec nos cellules de
renseignement pour qu'ils arrêtent
d'être dans le meilleur des cas borges,
dans le pire des cas aveugles ? On fait
quoi avec tout ça ? Alors des d'abord je
je pense qu'il y a eu euh attention hein
parce que là je tape. Il y a eu quoi ?
Dans le renseignement et dans les
prospectivistes des des personnes qui
pouvaient faire des des des constats
mais qui n'étaient pas forcément
entendu. Il y a eu des erreurs. Pourquoi
pourquoi elles sont pas entendues ?
Alors voilà, c'est pas alors plein de ch
plusieurs choses. D'abord euh vous savez
quand les alors pourquoi ? parce qu'il y
a du conformisme et eu la facilité
politicienne. C'estd que il y a des
cycles aussi he c'est vrai dans dans
beaucoup de domaines. Il y a eu une
convergence d'un conformisme
technocratique dans beaucoup de postes
pens une vraiment une façon de penser
les mêmes mots le même vocabulaire de
gens intelligents,
très souvent honnêtes et qui très
souvent je crois même la France mais qui
ne n'avait n'a jamais été n'ont jamais
pris un risque dans leur vie. Donc c'est
très compliqué de de se la base par
quand vous faites du renseignement quand
quand vous vous quand vous faites de ne
serait-ce que du commerce, on va
commencer par ça. La base c'est
d'essayer de réfléchir comme l'autre
partie. Alors c'est encore plus quand
c'est un ennemi. Mais quand l'autre
partie quand vous faites du commerce,
moi j'ai le [__] Non mais non
justement alors [__] quand c'est la
guerre mais quand quand moi je
travaillais dans le commerce quand on
faisait un contrat trop positif, moi
j'ai jamais voulu boire du champagne
après un contrat. On va laisser par
terre ou ou après on laisse pas les
lunettes par terre et on laisse pas par
terre après j'aurais dernière les
balancé. Mais euh donc à ce que je veux
dire c'est que de comprendre comment
raisonne l'autre parti et quel est son
intérêt. Donc quand on est dans le
domaine pacifié, dur, compétitif mais
pacifié du contrat, on essaie de faire
en sorte de trouver la fameuse solution
qui va nous permettre de gagner à
l'autre partie de gagner aussi. Ça
s'appelle le commerce. OK. Le donc il
faut toujours raisonner comme l'autre.
Pour raisonner comme l'autre, il faut
être en situation. À un moment donné, il
faut se frotter au réel. Il faut se
frotter à l'autre. Et on a eu une des
générations de dirigeants qui avaient
connu la guerre qui avaient connu la
guerre. qui étaient des gens assez
iconoclastes, qui étaient des gens assez
particuliers qui qui avaient une
personnalité forte des Chaban, des
Mesmer, des debrés, des de Gols, des
Méron en pense, bon même s'il a fait
beaucoup de mal à mes yeux mais qui
était donc il y avait des aspérités qui
pouvaient faire des sauts créatifs, qui
pouvaient renverser un raisonnement
comme on le fait dans une entreprise
tous les jours lorsqu'on est obligé de
de passer devant la concurrence ou de ou
d'aller sur un autre quand on voit qu'on
va se faire défoncer, on va ailleurs.
Enfin ou alors voilà, c'est c'est comme
ça. Or là, on est au bout d'un cycle qui
où il y a eu vraiment un conformisme de
de pensée, de géographie, de formation.
Ils sont c'est des gens très bien mais
ils sont interchangeables. Donc il en
faut mais pas trop. C'est comme le
cholestérol quoi. C'est une question de
proportion. Il y a des bons du mauvais
et c'est ce que j'appelais les petits
hommes non parce que ce serait trop trop
doulour trop douloureux trop ça devient
compliqué. Mais mais voyez et le et le
donc il y a ce conformisme là.
qui qui a qui qui produit toujours les
mêmes les les mêmes les mêmes notes. Moi
je les vois, je maintenant je suis
président des maires de France, j'ai des
rendez-vous, j'en rencontre, ils
produisent les mêmes trucs, ils ne
raisonnent il ils ne sont ni
pragmatiques ni visionnaires. Ils sont
dans un entre deux terrible.
Deuxème élément,
il y a la facilité politicienne
qui qui peut guetter chacun, hein. Donc
qui consiste à flatter l'opinion, à
rouler des mécanes. Réflex de Laurence,
c'est ça ? Oui. Puis à faire Oui. Et à
faire des séquences de com réflexe de
Lawrence ? Mais vous l'avez posé la
question à David. Donc je tous ceux qui
vous suivent ont déjà eu la réponse
récemment puisque David Bavrez y a
répondu. Le donc la
la
la la le réflexe politicien qui fait que
on a on on passe d'une séquence à
l'autre. Alors a la com est important en
politique. La communication ça fait
partie c'est intrinsèque mais c'est pas
une fin en soi.
La la meilleure communication c'est
l'information. C'est quand vous dites ce
que vous faites et puis ensuite vous
voyez comment ça réagit et puis et
cetera. Mais euh regardez le nombre de
plans qui ont été annoncés. Je faudrait
qu'on fasse un jour qu'on recense sur
les quatre dernières années les grands
effets d'annonce. Il y a eu un plan
vélo. C'est quoi l'exécution déjà ?
Comment est-ce à l'état de faire un plan
vélo ? Quoi ? débile. Il y a alors que
le monde s'écroule, qu'on a les les
frères musulmans, les islamistes que
qu'on maîtrise pas le régalien, les flux
migratoires qu'on a les Russes qui se
réarment, les Chinois qui se réarment
enf et nous on fait un plan vélo ça.
Oui. Oui. Mais vous vous savez, moi j'ai
été très lucide. Mais mes copains s'ils
regardent ça vont vont vont s'ouvrir
quand quand on parlera de l'Allemagne.
Non non mais je crois il y a eu un plan
il y a eu un plan il y a eu un plan haut
usé il y a eu donc tout ça est très
sympathique il y a eu un plan
préservatif dans les lycées
cit pas la bonne taille ça forcément et
bref et ensuite mais il y a pas
d'évaluation il y a pas c'est quoi la
hiérarchie des choses donc ce sont des
effets d'annonce et son mais oui mais je
réponds à votre question donc c'est
c'est mais c'est exactement l'étrange
défaite de Mark Block c'est c'est cette
double double perversité,
cette double détérioration, c'est-à-dire
des des élites dont les les modalités
deviennent des finalités, c'est-à-dire
le processus de de respect de la
hiérarchie devient on oublie même la fin
de ce que l'on fait et un délitement
moral parce qu'on oublie que pour être
prospère, pour être sûr, il faut faire
des efforts, il faut bosser. Quelle
était l'autre question ? Pardon. Avant
de poser la question, de la reposer, je
vous trouve profondément gentil et
franchement pas assez paranoïque. Alors
oui, d'abord je je trouve que la
gentillesse est une qualité et tant
mieux si je suis gentil. Pas assez
paranoïque. Vous avez pas l'impression
qu'on s'est fait entuber jusqu'en haut
de nos élites parce que on est quand
même la France. Comment on n' pas vu que
les Allemands nous mettaient des lokal à
Jean-Claude Vam pour nous mettre des
couteaux dans le dos, nous faire
trébucher ? Comment on n' pas vu que les
Américains nous infiltrent jusqu'à la
moelle, jusqu'à même Paris ? Comment on
n' pas vu les Anglais nous infiltrer,
les Russes et ainsi de suite. C'est
parce queon a des bénioui conformistes
et politi qui veut reformulez ce que je
viens de dire. Donc c'est ça. Bah oui,
c'est des bénioui politicards. Quand
j'ai pas avait pas un filet de sécurité
là-dedans, il y avait pas un mec qui
pourrait qui pouvait dire à notre chef
d'état "Attention là, ça avale trop fort
là." Mais je pense que le mec qui disait
ça, il restait pas. Euh, pardon. Mais et
alors qu'est-ce que vous ferez quand
vous arriverez au gouvernement ? Vous
allez virer tous ces béni Wiioui, vous
allez changer leur formation, vous allez
leur offrir des lacets, vous allez leur
faire un petit stage bad boy au Vietnam.
dans euh déjà je m'inspirerai de de ce
qui fonctionne ailleurs ou de ce qui a
fonctionné en France, c'est-à-dire de
créer de la liberté, de la
responsabilité chez les ministres qui
seront des patrons et c'est pas des des
termes en l'air. Moi ce qui me frappe
quand on a quand j'ai bossé avec
Christophe Tardieu sur le Pompidou, ce
qui nous a sidéré quand on a regardé les
archives, c'était la capacité d'action à
l'époque de ces gens-là. et mais il y
mais ils respectaient tous les
directives du président de la
République, mais ils étaient extrêmement
solides. Ensuite, ils allaient chercher
des porteurs de projet. C'est-à-dire que
quand on regarde les rends de réussite,
le nucléaire et cetera, c'était des
personnalités, des ingénieurs, des chefs
d'entreprise qui parlaient à des à des à
des politiques, ça devenait un un objet
d'agenda national et on construisait une
ambition sur ce qui était du du qui qui
était vraiment d'intérêt national.
Ensuite, le ce qui est certain, c'est
que
euh dès que vous arrivez, moi je l'ai vu
quand je suis arrivé dans une échelle
moindre à la mairie,
on tout le monde me disait "Tu ne
pourras pas baisser la dette, tu seras
obligé d'augmenter les impôts si tu veux
baisser la dette et tu ne pourras rien
faire de la masse salariale." C'est
archi faux. On a baissé la masse
salariale malgré tout ce qu'on nous
impose en charge supplémentaire de 12 %
dans une ville qui a un taux de pauvreté
bien sûr par à la moyenne nationale qui
a des charges énormes parce que il y a
des services de renseignement à Cann non
il y a d'accord qu'est-ce qu'on fait
avec nos services de renseignement qu'on
pas vu la guerre arriver donc on a
baissé donc je continue mon raisonnement
on a baissé la dette on sera 80 millions
d'euros de baisse dette ce qui est
énorme sur 10 ans. On baisse la
fiscalité de cette année 3,6 % et si je
dis pas qu'il le dira et on a multipé
par 8 la capacité d'autofinancement.
Pourquoi ? Parce que j'ai changé les
gens à la tête des directions. Ils ont
été mis en liberté et en responsabilité
et ils sont récompensés ou punis. Assez
simple. Responsabilité individuelle.
Moi, si demain je la responsabilité, la
charge de de mener le pays, les profils
qui seront à la tête de ces services
cruciaux seront des profils, je pense,
de personnalité plus forte que ce qu'on
a eu sans être insolent pour eux. Voilà.
Qui sont capables, moi j'ai toujours
demandé à avoir autour de moi des gens
qui sont capables de me dire ce que je
n'ai pas envie d'entendre. Le principe
de base, c'est la réalité. C'est la
réalité. Et d'ailleurs, une des sources
de la crise actuelle, c'est la
déconnexion du pays réel. C'est que le
pays réel, il reste super créatif, super
boss contrairement à ce que ce qu'on
entend toute la journée sur les médias.
Et ça, il faudrait me suivre 48 he pour
pour le voir parce que je parce que moi
je vais pas à la rencontre, je déteste
cette formule. Je vais à la rencontre
des Français. Il dit je vais à de
moi-même. Je suis un français quoi. Donc
je vis je vis en France, je vis pas sur
Mars. Et de temps en temps je viens
faire un petit séjour en France. Voilà,
je je vis dans mon pays et le fait
d'être président de ma je vais dans euh
voilà, je je rencontre des je vais voir
des salariés, des des des jeunes, des
étudiants, des des retraités, des des
des chefs d'entreprise et je vois les
élus locaux, 500000 élus locaux en
France, donc 490000
bénévoles, 400000 bénévoles et cetera.
Et je vois des gens super bosseurs qui
aiment le pays mais dans l'immense
majorité qui sont simples, qui veulent
que leurs enfants se fassent pas égorger
dans la rue, qui veulent de l'ordre, qui
en ont marre d'un état fort avec les
faibles et faibles avec les forts, qui
ne supportent plus la bouillie
politicienne qua. OK, ça c'est le pays
réel et puis il y a le pays légal.
Ce pays légal aujourd'hui, il a il a il
est il étouffe le pays réel et il a il a
il étouffe les initiatives par la
fiscalité, par les normes, par les
contraintes, par les injonctions
contradictoires qu'on reçoit tous les
jours quand on est dirigeant
d'entreprise, dirigeant d'une mairie,
dirigeant tout court, d'une même d'une
association.
Donc cette libération du PRL, c'est ce
qu'on évoquait tout à l'heure. Mais
ensuite
les aujourd'hui diriger un service de de
renseignement,
c'est évidemment avoir une vision.
Il y a quand même des gens de grande
qualité encore dans les services de
renseignement. Je je je veux pas je veux
pas vraiment ça m'embête de de tomber
dans les punitions collectives. J'ai
toujours détesté ça. Et vous me ferez
500 pompes. Oui, si vous voulez, je
serai surpris. le mais ça c'est que pour
le plaisir. Et pour revenir à la
punition,
ça ça fait quand même beaucoup le le le
non le tout c'est d'avoir vous savez
c'est c'est ces personnesl mais y
compris à Ber administration de super
niveau à Ber en réalité si vous n'avez
pas des une vision stratégique du pays
si vous ne dites pas voilà quelles sont
nos alliances voilà quels sont nos
intérêts voilà voilà voilà quels sont
nos principes nos intérêts nos principes
les moyens qu'on met en œuvre à la fois
budgétaire, technologique, financier,
militaire et diplomatique. Est-ce que
vous diligenterez une enquête interne
dans nos services de renseignement
intérieur extérieur pour savoir s'il y a
des ingérences étrangères ? De toute
façon, je je j'auditerai tous les
services, y compris les services de
renseignement en interne, un audit, un
truc,
on on a fait une alliance, moi je me
réjouis qu'on est petite fibroscopie.
Oui. Oui. Voilà. C'est c'est
ça dépend si c'est pour le plaisir ou
pour l'analyse mais le le Non mais plus
sérieusement le le voyez dans les Je
suis content j'arrive à vous désharsner
de temps en temps. Non mais
voyez par exemple qu'on ait une alliance
avec le Maroc c'est une bonne chose. Moi
je je m'en réjouis et cetera. Vous avez
eu un Pegasus sur votre téléphone mais
mais que on on n'est pas cherché à aller
plus loin, qu'on a pas plus analysé les
ingérences ou les les du Maroc à un
moment donné euh dans nos affaires
intérieures. Je trouvais ça bizarre.
Mais les Marocains, c'est les petits
joueurs, les anglais. Euh mais oui, mais
les anglais, la la la Turquie. La
Turquie, il faut parler de la Turquie.
Les Allemands, oui, les Allemands, pas
de problème. Moi, pour qu'on a on a un
rapport de force avec l'Allemagne qui
ensuite qu'on qu'on développe bien sûr
qu' qu'il faille des alliance européenne
avec l'Allemagne, mais d'abord qu'on
qu'on assume un leadership français. Moi
ça me va très bien, y compris vis-à-vis
de l'Allemagne. Est-ce qu'il faut ouvrir
des mines chez vos copains les mères ?
Euh alors, je sais pas chez ou copains,
mais il faut une une ambition minière.
Oui, oui, dans la France, y compris dans
les Frances d'outreem d'ailleurs mais
mais d'ailleurs c'était la chose la plus
intéressante qu'on a entendu l'Union
européenne ces derniers mois, c'était
bien cette volonté d'avoir une ouverture
de mine. Oui.
Oui. Oui. Je pense qu'il faut le faire.
Oui. Pourquoi ? parce que euh la
ressource minière euh est est une
ressource euh est un facteur de
développement et d'indépendance et donc
est une ressource stratégique et c'est
une source d'emploi, d'indépendance,
d'autonomie, de compétitivité
euh et c'est une et c'est un outil aussi
diplomatique très fort dans les
négociations avec d'autres pays.
Aujourd'hui, on est en totale dépendance
minière alors qu'on a des ressources
dans nos sous-sols et c'est une c'est un
des enjeux. Vous parlez de développement
de développement pour aller où ?
Je comprends pas la question. Pour aller
vers une société plus pacifiée, pour
aller sur une société plus prédatrice,
pour avoir la France comme maître du
monde pour aller où est dans l'espace
déjà.
D'accord. Euh
le
je je je pense que dans les finalités
ultimes de l'action publique
euh réside la dignité humaine
et la paix. Une fois qu'on a dit ça, ça
fait un peu Miss France mais c'est
essentiel. Donc le Et il faut jamais
l'oublier, ça fait Mister France. la
paix. Euh moi je dis souvent que la vous
savez la paix c'est comme la santé quoi
pour avoir enfin il y a que ceux qui
n'ont jamais vu ce qui était vraiment
une guerre qui qui peuvent fantasmer sur
la guerre. C'est vispassem parapem ou
parab c'estparam bellom. Donc c'est
vispem parabellom. Donc la l'enjeu c'est
d'essayer toujours d'avoir la la paix et
la dignité humaine. Donc ça passe par la
capacité de décision individuelle,
l'instruction, l'accès à la prospérité.
C'est c'est la finalité. Donc le
développement qui était votre question,
c'est passe par à la fois une croissance
matérielle mais aussi par un
développement euh
moral. Euh ça enfin pour moi c'est c'est
c'est vraiment un objectif. Mais vous
avez anticipé ce que je voulais dire.
C'est pas quand même par Abelom. Donc
tout ne peut euh exister que si on est
capable de faire la guerre euh dans le
monde reptilien parce que l'humain est
reptilien et donc le monde est reptilien
et ça n'a jamais cessé. Contre moi tout
ce qu'on nous dit quand on parlait de
dividend de de la paix. Moi ça ça me
rendait dingue déjà à l'époque. Bon euh
c'est comme ça qu'on qu'on s'est fait
déclasser, hein, et euh et qu'on a fait
du gaspillage et qu'on s'est mis en
dépendance des autres. Donc dans cet
univers-là, euh évidemment le le le
développement doit être un un
développement dont la finalité doit être
la paix, mais qui ne peut passer que par
une puissance militaire, une puissance
économique, une puissance scientifique
et éducative et euh une capacité
d'alliance qui dépendra de cette
puissance. Ensuite, vous avez parlé du
spatial.
Mais c'est c'est
le spatial
est aujourd'hui
par que vous avez ouvert des projets à
Cann pour aller dans le spatial. Je
disais le spatial c'était bien sûr que
si je sais exoars c'est à canne
aujourd'hui le siège social de la plus
grande
entreprise de spatiale française qui est
Talè Aina Space le siège social est à
canne enfin franco-italienne et on est
en train de se faire défoncer par les
italiens dans le spatial depuis 4 ans.
nos concurrents c'était les Allemands,
c'est les Italiens qui nous passent
devant et la seule usine d'intégration
complète de satellite en Europe, elle
est à Can c'est le plus gros employeur
industriel, c'est plus gros employeur
privés, c'est Tacan.
Et mais c'est pas c'est pas grâce à moi
et c'est indépendant de moi et
heureusement que c'est indépendant du
maire ou d'un politique. Heureusement
mais en revanche, on les accompagne sur
le foncier puisqu'en bord de mer du
foncier municipal a été mis à
disposition intelligente par un bail
amphithéotique donc qui nous permet
aussi de garder un intérêt parce qu' moi
je défends les contribuables et donc de
développer ce ce cet outil de
stratégique.
spatial aujourd'hui
est un un enfin c'est c'est un outil de
souveraineté, c'est un outil de
rayonnement.
On est en train de se faire tailler des
croupières dans le domaine, mais
ça renvoie aussi à
je je pas faire je vais continuer Miss
France là, mais c'est une une un pouvoir
onirrique, un pouvoir de rêve
qui peut amener plein de gamins vers les
les filières scientifiques. C'est le
renoncement de Saint-Pierre. Euh,
dites-moi. Et moi, quant à moi, je
sortirai de ce monde où l'action n'est
pas sœur du rêve. Oui,
revenons, revenons à nos moutons. Donc
donc il faut du rêve, il faut une
puissance onirique et aujourd'hui
les le spatial est un élément essentiel
non seulement de développement
économique, d'indépendance du pays, mais
aussi de de vocation pour nos jeunes.
Qu'est-ce qu'il vous racontent les gens
du spatial à Cann ? Bien euh ils vont
ils vous font miroiter des
constellations de satellites pour
cartographier les tubes de lave sur la
lune. Ils vous font miroiter euh des
satellites de la tarde d'une d'une
taille de crédit d'une carte de Non, il
faut rien miroiter du tout. Et ce qui
font miroiter peut-être l'orbitation euh
d'astéroïdes pour faire de
l'exploitation minière. Ce qu'ils me
disent c'est que si aujourd'hui on n'est
pas en mesure, c'est comme on parlait du
nucléaire, on on évite passer même sur
les sous-marins tout à l'heure, mais si
on n pas un travail de formation, ce
qu'il me disent c'est ça, hein, c'est
que un euh on se doit d'avoir des moyens
extrêmement puissants d'investissement
sur le spatial he et qui aurait été
délité et pas que sur les lanceurs, mais
aussi sur le satellitaire. Donc de
réorienter aussi les moyens
d'investissement sur le satellitaire. de
qu'il faut qu'on arrive à ne pas
forcément opposer le spatial classique
au newspace mais de raisonner en vision
globale et donc de faire solidarité
ascendante comme toujours cette DARPA
française et européenne pour mettre en
relation sur des projets structurés la
recherche privée publique, la force de
capitalisation privée et la force
d'investissement public sur des des des
projets stratégiques que j'ai pas à
qualifier à définir c'est pas mon rôle.
Euh 3 que si on de l'être non
oui pas forcément si vous êtes président
c'est-à-dire que président la République
il doit simplement lui créer les
conditions de la compétitivité et de la
convergence des moyens vers des objets
stratégiques mais c'est aux c'est aux
entrepreneurs et c'est aux c'est aux
ingénieurs de les définir. Ça a été ça a
été le génie de De Gol et de Pompidou
hein. Vous avez un un ego ? Un ego ?
Oui. J'ai de l'ego. Oui. Pourquoi ? Si
moi je vous propose en tant que
président de la République trois
projets. La cartographie des tunnels de
lave sur la Lune pour établir une base,
l'orbitation
d'astéroïdes pour faire de
l'exploitation minière et développer des
satellites en constellation pour
remplacer Starlink.
Vous choisissez quoi ? Euh je j'irai
vers la deuxième l'exploitation minière.
Ouais, parce que je pense que la
constellation
basse altitude pour remplacer Starlink,
on a pris on a pris beaucoup de retard
ou si on n pas de retard, elle pourra se
faire par des mécanismes plus classiques
du marché. elle sera beaucoup moins
dingue et stratégique que l'exploitation
minière
orbite qui peut à mon avis être une
source de de puissance déterminante.
Revenons à 1984, la vidéos surveillance,
les caméras, la sécurité, les coups de
couteau et et les road rage un peu
partout. Qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec tout
ça ? On développe plus d'intelligence
artificielle, de reconnaissance faciale.
On met plus de caméras, on met des
traceurs dans les téléphones portables,
on met tout le monde sur l'écoute. On
fait quoi ?
Euh c'est je le je l'apprendre pas comme
cela. C'estd que évidemment qu'il faut
plus de technologie et qu'il ne faut pas
laisser le monopole de la technologie
aux agresseurs, aux voyou, à ceux qui
blanchissent de l'argent, aux
terroristes évidemment. C'est que
refuser aujourd'hui d'utiliser cette
technologie là
c'est aurait été comme de refuser
d'armer la police euh parce que un
pistolet c'est mal ça tue quoi. Voilà,
c'est c'est qu'à moment donné des
principes de réalité et que si le ceux
qui ont le vi enfin celui qui a le
monopole de la violence légitime,
c'est-à-dire l'État n'a pas la violence
légitime légitime oui. Donc l'État c'est
c'est la vous savez c'est l'expression
de Max Weber. donc n'a pas la le le le
le la puissance technologique, enfin
l'outil technologique équivalent de ceux
qui veulent détruire la société, la
société sera détruite et que à un moment
donné
une société, une République, une
démocratie, ça doit pas être
l'impuissance,
ça doit être aussi la capacité de
défoncer, de détruire ceux qui veulent
nous détruire. C'est c'est c'est comme
ça. Bon, en revanche, la subtilité, la
force d'une démocratie neutralisé, c'est
peut-être mieux choisi. Oui, oui, oui.
Enfin, neutraliser, moi j'étais dans il
y a des univers où quand on utilisait le
terme neutralisé, c'était le plus
violent.
Ça voulait dire qu'on flinguait la
partie adverse. Bon, mais euh le mettre
hors d'état de nuire. Hors d'état de
nuire. Mais enfin bref, quand donc enfin
il y avait des services où quand vous
parlez de neutralisation, c'était un
état de une mise hors d'état de mur
définitive et absolue. Éteint la
lumière. Voilà, on on lui éteint la
lumière. Pour revenir à la question, la
faire à son ber et donc le
aujourd'hui cette technologie là,
l'utilisation de cette technologie ne
sont pas incompatibles avec le ce qui
fait une démocratie. et une démocratie
libérale, c'est-à-dire des principes
naturels qui s'imposent à nous. Et donc
c'est ce que c'est le contrôle
judiciaire. Alors après se pose la
question de la formation des juges, de
ce qu'on appelle le contrôle judiciaire,
c'est l'égalité des armes devant la
justice. C'est le contradictoire. Ce que
je veux dire par là, c'est que par
exemple moi en tant que maire, j'ai FCAN
aujourd'hui est la ville qui a le plus
de caméras par habitant. Donc j'ai
développé ça. Ça porte ses fruits. Oui.
Alors c'est jamais parfait mais ça porte
ses fruits dans alors parce que c'est
une île très compliqué can exposé.
C'estd qu'en fait on a officiellement
une population de 73000 habitants en
réalité on est classé 150000 400000 par
l'INC intramuros hein. Donc dès qu'on
rapporte des faits par habitant enfin
c'est c'est les choses par habitant sont
très peu comparables parce que c'est une
villez pas parce que on a le prem on a
le premier. Oui oui. Est-ce que ça porte
ses fruits comme à Dubaï ? Euh non. Duba
vous laissez votre téléphone par terre,
vous allez la demi-finale de Mais je je
veux pas que ça porte ses fruits comme à
Dubaï. Moi, j'ai pas envie de vivre à
Dubaï. Donc je je vous dire pourquoi ça
porte ces fruits mais c'est pas encore
assez parce que aujourd'hui ça a valeur
probatoire donc ça consolide
considérablement
les dossiers judiciaires
qui donc permettent d'appréhender des
des malfaisants. Combien de combien de
dossiers consolidés ? Mais c'est c'est
c'est plusieurs par jour. C'est
plusieurs par jour hein. Quel type
d'infraction ? C'est ça. Ça peut aller
du de du règlement de compte donc de de
à l'agression violente mais même à du
judiciaire sur un accident de la route.
Ça ça ça donne des éléments probatoires
qui sont extrêmement utiles, qui font
gagner du temps. Après ça pose la
question cam française ou des caméras
chinoises que vous avez. Je suis
incapable de vous le dire. Je je sais
pas vous le dire. Objectivement, je sais
pas vous le dire. Donc je veux pas vous
dire de bêtises mais j'espère que j'en
sais rien. Je veux pas vous le dire.
Mais le en tout cas c'est des caméras
efficaces technique d'un point de vue
technologique. Ensuite ça pose deux
questions. Ça pose la donc ça permet 1
c'est la force probatoire. De ça permet
de sécuriser les interventions des
forces de l'ordre lorsqu'il y a des
mouvements de violence urbaine.
Ça permet ensuite d'interpeller des
malfaisants. Pas toujours, mais ça peut
permettre de faire du flag. C'est
aléatoire ça. Ou de euh de suivre un
acte. Par exemple, récemment, on a
interpellé et ça c'est très bien et on a
chopé avec la police nationale police
municipale mais grâce aux vidéos du
service municipal des voleurs de
montrre. C'est parce que et et la vidéo
a été déterminante parce que les gens
qui suivent ça sont très habiles, sont
très bons. Ils voient des trucs qu'on
voit ou c'est mais c'est un moyen parmi
d'autres. Ce moyen-là est connecté à un
amont et un aval. L'aval,
c'est la sanction pénale et l'exécution
de la sanction pénale. Donc là, il faut
revoir beaucoup de choses.
La mon ou le ou en tout cas en même
temps, c'est est-ce qu'on peut utiliser
des technologies de reconnaissance
faciale ? Moi, je peux je pense qu'on
peut les utiliser avec des gardes fous
et et des gardes fous, c'est-à-dire que
ce soit sous contrôle judiciaire et que
la reconnaissance
faciale ou d'ailleurs c'est pas que
faciale, ça peut être la reconnaissance
d'un élément d'une carrosserie de
véhicule, j'ai j'ai on a on a testé des
logiciels qui sont phénoménaux
là-dessus, d'une démarche qui vient
d'une autorisation d'un magistrat
à partir d'un d'un deuil d'un seuil de
dangerosité individus. Il faut faire
très attention à ne pas installer le le
Big Brower parce qu'on a déjà Big Brower
hein, les les tanounou. Il faudrait pas
qu'on lui ajoute Big Brower, ça fait
beaucoup trop de Voilà. Donc euh c'était
Michel Schleder qui avait écrit un
bouquin génial hein, qui s'appelle Big
Mozer qui qui est Mathieu Len l'avait
repris aussi en partie dans dans l'état
nounou et cetera. Sur l'autre question
que vous me posiez. Oui. Donc sur
ensuite les sanctions, bah voyez euh
vous allez avoir toutes les caméras du
monde. S'il y a pas de sanction
derrière, ça devient du voyurisme du
voyurisme impuissant. Ce qu'il y a le
pire dans dans la vie d'un d'un être
humain, d'un homme. C'est si vous êtes
voyiste en plus impuissant, c'est ça
fait quand même de de travers. Donc euh
le le le le puisque vous aimez les les
métaphores imagées, le Ouais. C'est
mieux hein. Donc j'irai pas jusque là.
Donc le le Donc vous voyez quand quand
vous quand vous avez aux caméras euh
trois voyou 15 ans, on les met en tôle
où ? Ah bah c'est là qu'on en revient à
l'exper en disant voilà on va te mettre
des mines et on va te mettre des
prisons. Mais vous savez euh les les
maires ils sont ils vont être d'accord
mais mais moi demain vous me supprimez
toutes les règles débiles de zéro
artificialisation nette toutes les
contradictions et que j'ai un intérêt en
tant que maire à avoir une maison
d'arrêt je prends tout de suite une
maison d'arrêt hein. Enfin je veux dire
bien sûr je bien sûr je suis en train de
faire sur ma commune une unité de
traitement des déchets pour tout le des
Alpes maritimes. C'est c'est un projet
que je suis en train de de faire
aboutir.
Pardonnez-moi, c'est plus compliqué que
de faire une maison d'arrêt. Enfin, vous
ne croyez pas ? Ça aussi, j'en ai ralbol
d'entendre dire que les mères ne veut
Pourquoi on on refuse d'avoir des des
prisons très souvent aujourd'hui ? Parce
qu'on vous dit zéro artificialisation
nette. Vous ne p vous on vous cantonne
le foncier disponible mais on vous
limite, c'est que vous n'avez quasiment
plus le droit d'urbaniser pour des
raisons que je peux entendre. Mais en
même temps, on vous dira qu'il faut
faire une maison d'arrêt, qu'il faut
faire des écoles, euh qu'il faut
accueillir c et ça et pire, la maison
d'arrêt euh que vous avez qui vous
bouffera votre faible possibilité de
développement foncier et qui fera que
vous n'aurez plus d'autres projets ne
génère aucune recette. Il faut savoir
qu'une maison d'arrêt en France ne paye
pas la le foncier bâti. Donc non
seulement ça vous empêche d'avoir
d'autres projets, mais en plus vous
n'avez aucune rentrée fiscale. Si demain
vous dites l'Amérique a le courage
d'accueillir une maison d'arrêt aura un
bonus dans dans enfin je veux dire à un
moment donné la vie moi je crois que
qu'à ça il faut val c'est c'est une
question c'est une approche marchande un
peu avec les centrales nucléaires. Mais
mais oui mais c'est tellement évident
fait bosser c'estd que on peut pas vous
dire en même temps vous n'avez plus faut
faut bien comprendre le zéro
artificialisation net qui parle d'une
bonne attention dans le l'enfer est pavé
de on le sait depuis dente hein bon donc
le le donc oui il faut pas artif bien
sûr mais au lieu d'avoir d'avoir une
approche sur l'artificialisation qui
consiste à dire il faut il faudrait il
faudrait limiter l'artificialisation
donc il faut qu'on donne une valeur à
l'artificialisation voilà ce que ça
coûte en externité négative et on laisse
le principe de responsabilité de liberté
individuelle des des maires des élus sur
le contrat social local. Si vous faites
de vous continuez à faire des zones
commerciales pourries ou des zones
pavillires qui consomment de de
l'espace, OK, vous avez le droit. Mais
en terme de de ça vous donne droit à
moins de rentrée fiscale, ça vous crée
des bonus malus et là vous allez
responsabiliser faire du contrat social
local. Vous allez dire "Écoutez là
peut-être qu'il faut faire de la
verticalité ici, il faut peut-être
optimiser l'espace." C'est pas comme ça
que ça a été fait en France. On est
parti d'une approche totalement
technocratique sur des constats
d'ailleurs très faibles en disant on a
artificialisé 215000
euh euh km² machin ou et puis on va dire
qu'on va en faire que la moitié et on va
introduire ça dans des schémas régionaux
d'aménagement et de développement du
territoire qui vont s'imposer au plan
d'aménagement et de développement
durable qui vont s'imposer au plan de
développement durable qui vont s'imposer
au plan de mobilité urbaine qui vont
s'imposer au schéma de cohérence et
d'organisation territoriale qui vont
s'imposer au plan de au PLU, tout ça est
opposable au porteur de projet. À la
fin, vous ne pouvez plus avoir accès au
foncier entre les plans de prévention au
risque, entre le zéro artificialisation
net, le foncier est devenu ultra rare,
le foncier exploitable. Et on s'étonne
ensuite que le logement qui est plus de
logement, il y a que des génies qui
peuvent imaginer que ce qui est désiré
est rare coûtera moins cher et sera
accessible. C'est c'est il faut vraiment
fait des grandes écoles pour pour penser
cela. Mais quand dans la vraie dans la
vraie vie, vous savez que ce n'est pas
possible. Donc pour revenir à votre
question, moi demain, si vous avez
l'impression qu'on va enfin régler le
problème de la délinquence des mineurs,
si euh on ne vous pénalise pas
financièrement quand vous accueillez une
maison d'arrêt euh ou un centre de
redressement de mineurs, mais voilà.
Mais mais moi je veux vous dire qu'on va
en trouver des des on va en faire des
maisons d'arrêt. Évidemment, le maire de
Grâce a un projet de d'extension de sa
maison pénitentiaire, son maison
péniteniaire. Pour l'instant, il y a pas
de suite de l'État. Voilà, il faut faut
donc évidemment qu'il peut y avoir des
résistances de mère mais pour des bonnes
raisons parfois mais je vous assure
qu'on est pas débile quand on est mè pas
tous et je et moi la majorité des maires
je vois l'immense majorité c'est des
gens très concrets très bien et
pragmatiqu mais c'est très on est au
cœur du sujet voyez avec Alexandra
Martin qui qui est député de de Cann on
a rédigé ensemble une proposition de loi
pour que il y ait on a on a travaillé
avec le docteur Berger là-dessus sur
donc pédopsychiatre pour dire et c'est
qu'il faut que les les les mineurs
délinquants graves et tout de suite une
sanction. Ça le contraire de ce qu'a
fait l'ancien garde des saut du pont
Moreti qui a créé ce qu'on appelait la
saisure entre la reconnaissance de la
culpabilité devant un tribunal de
mineurs et ensuite l'application de la
sanction. C'est qu'il a laissé une
période pour voir si le mineur se
comportait bien ou pas et cetera. Donc
il sort le mineur, il se dit "J'ai
rien." Et il repasse à l'acte.
Malheureusement, ce sont des mineurs qui
avaient été reconnus coupables
mais avec la saisure qui ont tué euh
Elias dont la mère était ce matin euh
sur un un grand média national et dont
le témoignage était extrêmement fort. Et
euh donc il est évident et on le sait
tous, on a été gamin, on a transgressé.
Sauf que le degré de transgression,
lorsque vous avez un permis de
transgresser, vous montez la
transgression. lorsque vous vous avez
des familles qui ne sont plus des
familles. Donc il faut une il faut que
la transgression ait des réponses
graduer parce qu'on est en démocratie
mais réelle et forte et à forceourie
lorsque la transgression elle est
abjecte et barbare c'est-à-dire qu'elle
s'attaque à la vie humaine ou ou donc
cette il doit y avoir une réponse
immédiate qui doit viser à protéger
d'abord la société en enfermant et en
privant de liberté réellement le le le
le délinquant. quel que soit son âge et
ensuite qui doit qui doit rassurer la
victime et qui doit aussi sur des
transgressions moins graves qui
permettra à des gamins dans un régime
disciplinaire de retrouver euh une
colonne vertébrale. On lui fait payer
l'incarcération ou pas ? Moi je j'ai
toujours été pour. C'est des systèmes
que je trouve plutôt sains. Voilà. Quel
calif ? Euh alors le le coût journalier
d'une place de prison mais je je
mentira si c'est faux. De mémoire je
crois que c'était 110 €.
Euh donc je sais pas si on peut faire
payer 110 € mais je trouve que de toute
façon rien n'est gratuit. Donc tout ce
qui permet de tarifer et de montrer la
réalité parce que c'est la gratuité dans
un service public, ça s'appelle l'impôt
pour la gratuité pour l'usinage, c'est
l'impôt pour le contribuable.
Dites-moi. Oui, on a on a fait les
l'évaluation de
des potentiels risques économiques
d'industrialisation, de
réindustrialisation,
de PIB, de retraite, de pyramide des
âges, de natalité. D'ici 10 ans, vous
voyez le régime politique français
prendre quelle tournure
avec les phénomènes exotiques extérieurs
qui vont mettre notre société à mal ?
Je C'est les phénomènes exotiques
extérieurs, c'est donc les menaces qu'on
a évoqué tout à l'heure. C'est quoi ?
Qu'est-ce que vous qu'est-ce que vous
mettez par s'il vous plaît dans la dans
dans cette est-ce que la France va virer
euh plus vers une dictature ou une
démocratie qui se tend ou est-ce que la
France
va continuer d'être une vraie
démocratie, si on peut appeler ça une
vraie démocratie ? Euh
il faudrait qu'on qu'on redevienne
totalement une vraie enfin totalement
que qu'on la démocratie est un système
imparfait comme disait Churchill hein.
C'est le pire des systèmes après tous
les autres.
Mais euh la dans démocratie et pour
répondre à votre question, il y a Demos
le peuple et il y a Cracisie pouvoir.
C'est très important parce que je suis
archi convaincu que d'abord votre
question elle est fondamentale. C'est
qu'on est au cœur de de d'ailleurs dans
dans mon livre je pars de ça. Je dis
qu'on est dans une crise de la
démocratie que si et c'est ce que dit
Pompidou dans dans ce dans cette
conclusion magnifique du New Gordien
lorsqu'il dit il nous faudra trancher.
il pose ces questions sur la le rapport
à la science, à la liberté, à
l'exécution des choses et il nous faudra
trancher ce nœud gordien non pas à la
manière casquée d'Alexandre mais à la
manière de démocrate.
Donc moi je je veux je veux croire que
la démocratie a de l'avenir et je pense
que l'enjeu c'est précisément de
défendre la démocratie. On entend
beaucoup dire autour de nous et parfois
on peut le penser ce qui est une erreur.
Moi je l'ai entendu de de personnes que
je connais compris dans ma famille de
gens pourtant raisonnable tellement
ralbol de l'impuissance publique face à
ceux qui nuisent qui détruisent ralbol
parce que quand vous prenez un excès de
vitesse, vous êtes sûr d'être sanctionné
et ce qui est certainement normal mais
si votre bagnole brûle que vous arrêtez
celui qui l'a fait brûler vous êtes sûr
qu'il n'est pas sanctionné donc vous
renvoyez les gens vers l'abstinence
civique ou les votes extrêmes. C'est
tellement évident tellement évident.
Donc la première cause de la crise de la
démocratie, c'est avant tout une crise
de l'exécution des choses. Et à ce
titre, la crise de la démocratie, on
nous a toujours dit que c'est une crise
de la représentation. Moi, je crois que
c'est avant tout une crise du Kratos, du
pouvoir. Donc pour répondre à votre
question, tout ce que j'essaie de
développer avec Nouvelle énergie, c'est
pour redonner et c'est d'ailleurs en
cela que c'est intéressant, c'est que
c'est un projet libéral qui va redonner
une capacité d'exécution à l'État. Mais
un état qui va pas s'occuper euh de nous
dire combien de fois il faut laver sa
chemise et son slibat son caleçon. Euh
vous avez vu ça quand même il y a 2 mois
avec vos impôts et mes impôts, une
campagne a été financée pour nous dire
que il valait mieux nettoyer son caleçon
c'est via LAADEM euh tous les jours,
mais qu'une chemise, on pouvait la
mettre je crois 2 jours et euh un short
pour faire du sport plusieurs jours.
Donc euh non seulement Big Nounou est
pénible mais en plus Big Nunou est
cravingue quoi. C'est c'est je n'invente
rien. Donc quelle était ma question ?
Ben votre question c'était où sera notre
démocratie dans quelques années ? Donc
dans dans 10 ans. Voilà. Donc français
sera prendre à quelle tournure avec des
phénomènes exogène stressant ? Mais ça
ne veut ça veut dire que la la
sauvegarde de la démocratie pour moi est
une fin, n'est pas qu'un moyen, c'est
une fin, c'est une finalité. Il faut la
sauvegarder et que pour la sauvegarder,
il faut qu'elle soit efficace. et que
pour qu'elle soit efficace, c'est le
projet que j'essaie de développer,
c'est-à-dire de réduire le périmètre de
l'action publique pour recentrer
l'action publique sur ce qui est
stratégique et notamment enfin ce qui
est le régalien en particulier et la
finalité c'est la justice de l'action
publique par-dessus tout donc c'est la
sauvegarde des intérêts de la France et
ensuite de recréer une prospérité parce
que dans le cas contraire avec un coup
de baguette magique non pardonnez-moi on
va ouvrir des pu de pétrole en France
mais du gaz de chist est-ce que vous
êtes pour le gaz de chiste à canne mais
gaz de chiste Mais vous vous vous savez,
c'est une façon rhtorique de dire
regardez ça c'est un populaire donc vous
êtes capable d'accueillir chez vous. Je
je pense que produire faire de la
méthanisation à canne et euh faire de
l'hydrogène vert à canne comme on va le
faire dans un mois et faire des déchets
une ressource n'est pas plus compliqué
que de que de faire autre chose. Alors
je ne sais pas s'il y a une ressource.
Donc ça bien l'hydrogène vert. Écoutez
l'hydrogène qui est qui une unité de
production locale qui est connectée à du
nucléaire, ça marche bien. Oui. Ah oui,
du nucléaire. Bah bien sûr. Oui, c'est
pour ça que c'est ver d'ailleurs et donc
le le donc pour revenir à votre
question, je je moi j'accepte pas le en
disant que c'est un coup de baguette
magique quand on on travaille nous
sérieusement sur la location sociale
unique, sur les le plan à 200 milliards,
sur le fait de dire que le taux de TVA
c'est pas TVA social ou pas, c'est pas
la question qu'il faut supprimer les 108
régimes dérogatoires de taux de TVA qui
font 108 exceptions qui coûtent 50
milliards d'euros. parents à l'État.
Enfin, je sais pas moi, c'est un travail
extrêmement fin. Donc c'est pas du tout
par un coup de baguette magique, mais il
n'y a pas de fatalité
au des classements français. Le ce que
la France a su faire, la France a été a
une somme de de on le disait tout à
l'heure, de période de prospérité, une
somme de période d'effondrement. Donc
soit on accepte l'effondrement, soit on
se barre à l'étranger, on devient
spectateur et commentateur et ça peut
être une tentation hein qu'on peut
ressentir. Je peux ressentir aussi et je
je vois autour de gens autour de moi
hélas des gens qui se barrent ou qui a
cette tentation. Soit on essaie encore
de dire que il y a une force civique,
une énergie civique en France qui fait
que face à ces menaces extérieures et
bien ces menaces extérieures ne sont
fortes que nos faiblesses intérieures et
c'est tout ce que j'ai évoqué tout à
l'heure sur cette ambition sécuritaire
libérale pour la la prospérité
sécuritaire sur l'ordre et pour l'unité
de la nation par la par la la culture
l'éducation et la science d'histoire
pardon vous êtes féru d'histoire ça
m'intéresse féru ça voudrait dire que
que j'ai une compétence Je pense que je
n'ai pas mais oui, ça m'intéresse. Je
pense qu'on ne peut pas regarder le
regarder l'avenir sans regarder essayer
de comprendre comment ça s'est passé un
petit peu avant. Ouais. Vous avez étudié
quelques empires qui se sont cassés la
binette dans l'histoire. Bah les les
incas se sont bien cassés la gueule.
Oui. L'Empire romain aussi. Qu'est-ce
qui de commun entre ce cassage de gueule
des deux côtés ?
Ah, je pense la l'absence de perception
du du risque de l'extérieur
et euh et donc qui met en en faiblesse
euh en fait, c'est de vivre sur ses
acquis, si je vais le résumer de façon
la plus la plus simple possible, c'est
de vivre sur les acquis. C'est le plus
compliqué, c'est de c'est de ne pas
rester sur les acquis. C'est c'est c'est
des c'est d'échapper aux idées
anciennes. C'est pas de C'est le plus
dur des pas de de comprendre les idées
nouvelles, c'est d'échapper aux idées
anciennes. Oui. Donc euh Oui. Au régime
politique français d'ici 10 ans, c'est
ce qui fait que les incass sont fait
atomiser. C'est ce qui fait que les
Romains sont fait envahir l'intérieur.
Les cas, ils sont fait atomiser à cause
des virus européens aussi. Bah oui. Oui.
Mais enfin oui, ils sont pointés à 100,
ils ont mis plus de 20 millions de
personnes à terre.
Donc revenons au régime français d'ici
10 ans. Quand on va mettre
l'intelligence artificielle implémenté
dans la vidéosurveillance, dans la
reconnaissance faciale, dans la
l'interprétation des datas, qu'on a des
phénomènes exogènes stressants comme la
géopolitique agressive, la décrue de
notre consommation énergétique
et gens passé des meilleurs des pénuries
sur les matières premières. Est-ce que
vous avez pas l'impression qu'on va
laisser des lames de rasoir au futur ?
présidentiable. Alors oui, je vois ce
que vous voulez dire mais mais c'est une
c'est peut-être pas très clair. Si si.
C'est-à-dire que le problème c'est qu'on
met en place des outils d'efficacité qui
peuvent être utilisés par un dictateur.
C'est ça que vous voulez dire ou j'ai
rien compris ? Oui. Oui. Et c'est-à-dire
qu'on est sur la route avec des
phénomènes exogènes, des phénomènes
exotiques qui vont mettre nos
démocraties en mode très stressé. Mais
c'est cela que la pardonnez-moi al ça
vous parle une mais que la démocratie
est toujours très fragile mais donc ce
qui peut détruire la démocratie c'est si
des les derniers outils sont des outils
de contrôle social absolu et détruisent
les libertés et moi qui est
contrairement à ce que vous pensez
beaucoup de paranoïa qui a grandi en
lisant la ferme des animaux orwell 1984
et même et tous ces éditau qui adorent
le dystopique qui adore le qui élu
l'ccraft Enfin toutes ces chosesl que
vraiment donc j'ai bien plus de paranoï
que vous le pensez et pour citer encore
Woody Allen Wooden disait ce n'est pas
parce que vous êtes paranoï que vous
n'avez pas d'ennemis dans cette phrase.
Bon mais je dirais pas que vous êtes pas
pas assez paranoïque, vous êtes
peut-être pas assez alerte. Non non mais
si si mais il en c'est comme tout, il en
faut un degré mais pas trop quoi. C'est
c'est comme le ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure. Mais ce que ce que je veux dire
c'est que parallèlement ce qui peut
aussi détruire la démocratie c'est de ne
pas avoir les outils d'efficacité. Et
c'est là qu'il y a toute la subtilité et
qu'il faut confier les reennes à des
gens qui sont profondément tournés vers
l'exécution des choses et la recherche
de performance et notamment de
performance publique mais qui sont
profondément démocrates. C'est c'est
comme ça. Et donc le et cela passe aussi
par une évolution du régime qui doit
revenir d'ailleurs à son esprit plus
originel et on ne peut plus faire
concentrer autant de pouvoir sur une
seule personne. La performance,
l'efficacité, c'est aussi le
foisonnement. En économie, on le sait
très bien, AEC
l'a très bien démontré. C'est la
discussion sur est-ce qu'on ordonne ou
pas, est-ce qu'on régule ou pas, il y a
des débats sans fin y compris au sein
des libéraux. Mais c'est K ou AEC ? Mais
AEC. Ah mais AEC, l'ordre spontané. Euh
et après Kenson, il y a eu une
interprétation Kens qui a été déviée.
Mais non, AEC, la source la la matrice,
c'est l'ordre spontané. Puis la route de
la servitude reste un bouquin
incontournable. Incontournable. Mais
l'ordre spontané, c'est le foisonnement.
C'est la liberté comme source de la
création. C'est l'intérêt de l'individu.
Ce qu'on retrouve dans chez Nrand.
Alors, chez Enrond, ça va très très
loin. Mais quand vous lisez la source
vive d'rond la la la force de la
production, c'est aussi une forme de de
c'est elle elle parle d'égoïsme
et et c'est un outil de développement
extraordinaire, de chercher son intérêt,
d'où la notion de propriété. Il ne peut
pas y avoir de prospérité s'il n'y a pas
le carré magique que constitue la
liberté comme source de création, la
responsabilité comme corolaire de la
liberté, la dignité humaine qui est la
finalité de tout et la propriété qui est
la condition synéquanonne de la liberté.
On n'est pas en liberté si on a pas de
propriété privée. Donc la démocratie
libérale, c'est celle qui fait de ces
outils d'efficacité l'intelligence
artificielle implémenter la caméra et
cetera. des outils qui ne remettent pas
en cause la sphère privée qui est une
conquête majeure de de la démocratie
libérale occidentale. La sphère privée
et la liberté d'où la nécessité du d'où
le chiffrement la partiellisation des
données, la le la décentralisation
l'organisation d'une société où il doit
y avoir le moins de nœud de
centralisation. Euh c'est vrai pour les
données mais c'est vrai aussi dans la
prise de le pouvoir. C'est pour ça que
je plus j'avance en expérience, plus je
suis pour euh ce qu'on appelle les
référendum d'initiative citoyennes, ce
qui était pas ma tendance naturelle. Le
modèle suisse est très intéressant,
c'est-à-dire et et de le les derniers
ouvrages aussi bien de de Raphaël Doan
que de Samuel Fitosi sont à lire.
Pardon Samuel Fit aussi il est
brillantissime. Et Raphaël Doan aussi
les deux c'est des jeunes hommes je sais
pas ils ont 30 piges quoi. Non non
Samuel c'est c'est on a reçu le père. Ah
oui le père parce que le père brillant
mais le le il faut parce que Samuel Fit
aussi pour com il était mais vraiment
brillantissime. Et les deux lui il écrit
un livre sur pourquoi les intellectuels
se trompent. il démontre que plus on
fait d'études, plus on est pas si c'est
son père d'ailleurs et et et deux et et
deant justement sur le fait de dire que
les que souvent les on s'imagine que la
la l'intermédiation est un garde fou et
en réalité c'est souvent dans des
régimes où il y a beaucoup
d'intermédiations que les dictateurs ont
pris le pouvoir. Revenons sur le
chiffrement.
H vous êtes pour l'affaiblissement du
chiffrement avec une bague d'our que la
DGSE pourrait avoir.
J'ai beaucoup de mal à vous répondre à
ça. Ah oui ouais. Pourquoi donc ? Parce
que euh parce que ça protège les
dealers, c'est ça ? Non non mais oui.
Alors je vais vous dire euh je je non je
je ne suis pas pour parce que je pense
que on
précisément on ouvre la porte à quelque
chose de très liberticide.
On ouvre la porte à d'autres et et on
ouvre la porte à d'autres. Donc s'il
faut trancher, je pense qu'on a d'autres
outils qui sous un contrôle judiciaire
par la tracçabilité notamment des
portail et c nous permettrait et si on
avait une politique pénale ferme d'être
beaucoup plus efficace face à des à de
la grande délinquence à du grand
manditisme que d'ouvrir cette bague d'or
qui vraiment représente un danger.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez que Pavel
Durof soit sous contrôle judiciaire en
France depuis plus de 8 mois ? J'ai j'ai
écrit un tweet qui m'a fait valoir de
je trouve ça très Alors cette histoire,
je veux pas être très précis donc je
serai pas à la hauteur de des espérances
et et du niveau de de de votre média
parce que c'est un média. Mais euh j'ai
pas compris le non je je je je parce que
je vais vous répondre un peu en non pas
en normand mais mais j'ai j'ai dans dans
c j'ai une tronçonneuse dans dans cette
affaire je je il y a il y a quelque
chose de d'extrêmement étrange et j'ai
fait un tweet quasiment complotiste
puisque je me suis pas des complotistes
euh je ne je ne comprends pas ce qui
s'est passé avec du je ne le comprends
toujours pas et j'espère le rencontrer
prochainement puisqu'il est possible
qu'il vienne dans ma commune
prochainement pour une grande
manifestation
où on m'a demandé dans quelques semaines
rappelez-nous parce qu'il faut qu'on
voit.
Donc donc voilà, mais il y a il y a il y
a quelque chose derrière ça d'absolument
curieux dans l'approche de la France et
dans la dans la de de ce dossier. Voilà,
j'en dis pas plus parce que j'ai pas
plus d'infos, mais uniquement par
raisonnement et et et par par approche
analytique
le le fait de de
enfin de ce revirement de cette il y a
une approche très curieuse dans le
dossier du ROF et je pense qu'un jour on
apprendra des choses sur cette affaire.
Oui oui. La grande manifestation à Can
c'est dans quel contexte ? C'est une
manifestation une des grandes
manifestations qui a eu au palais des
festivals et des congrès de Cann qui est
devenu le premier de France en ch
d'affaires devant Paris. C'est une
grande fierté pour notre ville mais j'en
dis pas plus parce que je j'ai pas à le
dire. Il y a beaucoup de vieux à Cann.
Il y a beaucoup de vieux dans le monde
de plus en plus. Il y a beaucoup de
vieux monde. Euh Cann a une pyramide des
âges qui est plutôt en sablié. Donc en
proportion de la population, on en a
moins que que Menton Limoge, on en a
plus que d'autres villes. On est je
pense légèrement tu l' nationale en plus
de 60 ans mais aussi en moins de 20 ans.
Donc l'enjeu, c'est d'élargir le la
franche des actifs. Question internet,
les retraites c'est des dépenses
publiques. Oui, il faut baisser les
retraites des retraités trop payés.
Point d'interrogation. Je Alors, il faut
passer à la capitalisation
obligatoire. Mais maintenant, ah bah
c'est la base de tout. Et pardonnez-moi,
ça fait 10 ans, bah il faut passer
rapidement contrairement moi à ce qui me
s pas à la capitalisation.
Euh un, on ne peut plus indexer pour moi
les retraites et en particulier les
retraites de plus de 2000 € par mois
netes. Alors donc je le dis et je pense
que les le le et pour en parler avec des
parce que là aussi je ne supporte plus
les les politiques qui pensent qu'ils
vont assurer leur réélection en pensant
que le retraité ne se voit que comme un
retraité qui touche une retraite. pour
discuter avec beaucoup de retraités,
beaucoup de retraités sont capables
comprennent très bien qu'à partir d'un
certain seuil de retraite, vu que c'est
les actifs qui payent, ce n'est plus
soutenable, depuis les années 60, 60 %
de l'augmentation de la dette publique
est d aux retraites.
Sur les 10 dernières années, c'est sur
pardon les 7 dernières années, c'est
plus de 50 milliards d'euros de dette de
500 milliards d'euros de dette
supplémentaire qui a dû au retraite.
Donc, on ne peut plus
enfin mettre la tête dans le sable face
à cela. Donc la base de tout, c'est
d'arriver à faire la transition vers une
partie en capitalisation obligatoire
collective, mais dans l'immédiat pour la
transition et pour alimenter notamment
la retraite par capitalisation. Je pense
que la nonindexation des retraites
au-dessus d'un certain niveau qui doit
être défini politiquement, ça doit être
il faut une légitimité pour le faire,
une élection euh il faut expliquer
serait tout à fait admise. Des retrait
beaucoup de retraités euh sont le
comprennent, certains ont un patrimoine
et serait d'accord si ça sert les
enfants et les petits-enfants. Le
problème aujourd'hui c'est que vu queon
nous a tellement parlé de
d'assainissement des comptes publics
sans qu'il assaignissement des comptes
publics, tout le monde se recroque
vieille de façon égoïste de façon
légitime et pertinente sur ses intérêts.
C'est pour ça qu'il faut recréer de la
confiance et qu'il faut vraiment
asseaignir les comptes publics.
Imaginez, on va faire une expérience de
pensée ensemble. Euh vous accédez à la
fonction suprême,
des émeutes gigantesques arrivent parce
qu'on va se retaper on se retaperait 25
% d'inflation.
On se retrouve avec des gens très très
fâchés dans les rues. Alors de toute
opinion politique, de tout secteur
d'activité, vous gérez comment la crise
? Le risque inflationniste
est réel, hein, sans déconner. Sauf que
99 % des élus vous interrogez vous vous
diront biaiseront là-dessus.
Il est réel si on ne n'arrive pas très
très vite à retrouver une politique
énergétique cohérente, effective et
puissante. Premièrement. Deuxièmement,
si dans la compétition des capitaux que
j'évoqué tout à l'heure,
on est les plus dépendant des capitaux
des autres, donc qu'on est obligé
d'augmenter de ton intérêt.
Euh je sais pas si c'est l'inflation qui
créerait les émeutes, ça j'en sais rien.
Je vais je vais résumer trivialement
parce que très souvent les les émeutes,
elles sont venues d'autres phénomènes he
en France. D'accord. le les émeutes
quand il y a eu le le
le Nail qui a été ça rien à voir avec
l'inflation ça ça rien à voir avec
l'inflation. Vous avez pas vu ça comme
des émeutes de la fin ? Non non quand
vous voyez des gars aller dans des des
supermarchés d'entrée de gamme piquer
des crèmes hydratantes, des couches pour
gamin et de la lessive, c'est pas des
émeutes de la pauvreté. Non non non, je
crois pas. C'était pas un contexte
suffisant pour aller faire de de des non
je crois pas que c'était des émeutes de
pauvreté. Je je vous parle
objectivement. Je crois pas que c'était
des émeutes de pauvreté. On va parler,
on se retr Non non mais voilà, je crois
pas que c'est des émeutes de pauvreté.
Je émeutes de quoi ? Bah c'était c'est
meut il y a il y a un phénomène qui
enclenche, il y a cette violence de
cette vidéo du gars voilà avec le le
coup de feu et les émotes dans les les
émotes se font avec
un effet boule de neige comme on avait
eu sur les précédentes émeutes qui
étaient pas des émeutes de pauvreté non
plus et ensuite des émeutes
d'opportunité. C'estàd qu'une fois qu'on
pille les vitrines, on pille les
vitrines, on prend des biens matériels,
mais c'est pas euh c'est pas la pauvreté
et la fin qui ont qui ont motivé 99 %
des émettiers. Ça, je suis sûr que non.
Et le pillage, qu'est-ce qui a motivé le
pillage ? La le le fait de prendre des
biens, l'absence de de repères moraux
comme toujours, on en revient toujours à
ça, serait faire insulte aux pauvres que
de penser que ces émetiers là volaient
pour pour bouffer, hein. C'est vraiment
une insulte à tous les pauvres qui ne
qui ne volent pas. et l'immense majorité
des gens voyes déboîé à la voiture
Bélier.
C'est quoi ? Ben c'est de l'me c'est
c'est un effet d'entraînement et et et
de l'opportunité pour prendre des biens
évidemment mais c'est pas une émeute de
pauvreté, c'est pas la cause n'est pas
la pauvreté parce que c'est parce que je
répète que l'immense majorité des
pauvres en France n'ont pas fait des
meutes. Voilà c'est et c'est comme ça et
qu'il y a j'ai il y a trop de pauvres
qui se comportent bien pour qu'on
assimile pas ça à des émeutes de
pauvreté. C'est parce que nos pauvres
sont des C'est parce que nos pauvres se
tiennent bien que les politiques font
n'importe quoi. Non, c'est Non, non, je
crois pas. C'est que euh non, je sais
pas je sais pas répondre à cette
question mais c'est je je les ce que je
veux dire, c'est que le phénomène de la
violence ou de l' meut, il est il dépend
de facteurs qui sont très compliqués à
analyser et c'est souvent dans des
périodes de prospérité qu'il y a des
phénomènes de violence dans nos
démocraties. Je 68 par exemple en est en
est l'expression qui qui ont été une
vraie violence. Alors avec le recul, il
ont dit que c'était des fausses émeutes
et cetera, mais enfin ça a été stimulé.
Après, il y avait derrière des des des
influences étrangère, ça c'est sûr. Ça
on le sait d'ailleurs, c'est documenté
maintenant. Mais euh mais c'était aussi
mais c'est s mais vous savez les révol
étrangères de qui à l'époque elles
étaient doubles encore elles étaient
doubles. C'était c'était américain et
russe quoi. On a d'après ce qu'on a pu
en tout cas ce que certains on ont dit
de façon assez sourcé d'ailleurs. Mais
euh pour revenir à la à la question
c'est comment vous gérez les émotes ?
Bah les émotes, vous savez vous n'avez
d'autres d'autres choix euh que de
rétablir l'ordre. C'est c'est comme ça.
C'est c'est d'accord. C'est comment vous
allez à la télé en disant rentrez chez
vous attention je vais envoyer l'armée
c'est votre question objectivement je ne
me paraît pas être une bonne question
parce que c situations de crise type
ne ne se gère que quand elle se gère
quoi. Donc tout dépend de clients
clenché les mots aussi est-ce qu'il y a
Merci. Est-ce qu'il y a un est-ce qu'il
y a un un fact tout dépend du facteur
enclenchant, tout dépend de est-ce qu'il
y a des leaders ou pas. Donc les émotes,
elles se gèrent en praticien de de
l'ordre public tout le temps. Tout le
temps, tout le temps. On les les gilets
jaunes, ça a été géré en pr en praticien
ou ça a été géré comme des techniques de
contre-insurrection digne d'un pays du
tiers monde ? Je je je alors euh un euh
les le premier
je si vous voulez, il y a un peu d'eau
sur votre gauche. Non non non, la
technique non c'est compliqué parce
qu'il y a eu plusieurs vagues, il y a eu
plusieurs phases dans dans le mouvement
gilets jaunes et
la le problème c'est que moi le des
gilets jaunes qui qui révélait vraiment
ça c'était tiens ça c'est intéressant
c'était un mouvement social pour moi
travailleurs pauvres de oui beaucoup
plus de travailleurs pauvres ou de de
personnes qui qui se sentaient dans ce
qu'on a rien que le langage les
interstices
c'est c'est donc quand on vous dit ah
ben tu habites dans une zone
intersticiel, bah tu as de quoi te
révolter. Ça ça me paraît évident. C'est
c'est ce que comprennent absolument pas
les les dirigeants, les les haut
fonctionn ils ne comprennent pas toute
cette France. Et donc ça c'était
intéressant parce qu'il y avait un côté
jacri euh face à un problème de de de
pouvoir d'achat qui venait la taxe sur
sur les carburants et sur le rôle
indispensable de l'automobile qui est
indispensable. C'est ce qu'on retrouve
dans les aides des feux. C'est ce qu'on
retrouve dans dans le rejet des des feux
de du mouvement desgux d'Alexandre
Jardin. Et euh donc pour revenir à votre
question, les doctrines d'emploi et de
dispersion des gilets jaunes euh
ne sont pas à la hauteur d'une grande
démocratie. Ouais, moi je le je le pense
et là si vous arrivez au pouvoir et je
le pense mais donc mais c'est des
émeutes qui sont motivés par le prix du
carburant, l'inflation sur le la façon
le mouvement des gilets jaunes est
devenu un mouvement est devenu aussi un
mouvement d'extrémistes toujours le
problème c'est qu'il y a des casseurs et
que face à ces ces infiltrations de
casseur vous êtes obligé de de il faut
casser les casseurs pour faire du du
néopascois vous êtes obligé de faire ça
c'estd que le le problème c'est que ces
casseurs entraînent ensuite une spirale
infernale de l'émot
Donc il faut il faut cribler. Comment
arrivons-nous ? Enfin, on doit pouvoir
cribler ces casseurs, me semble-t-il. Il
y a une capacité quand même de
renseignement territorial pour cribler
ces casseurs, pour les neutraliser. Euh
au fait quoi avec le le narcotrafiquant
? Le narcotrafic, il ne peut être réglé
en partant du principe que la drogue est
interdite euh que euh si l'action des
pouvoirs publics est est est tous
azimute. C'est-à-dire que c'est une
action évidemment euh répressive
et euh de de prison de haute sécurité.
Donc ça va la la loi narcotraique
euh et les annonces là-dessus récentes
sont vont dans le bon sens. Mais ça ne
suffira pas si parallèlement il y a pas
un travail énorme sur le blanchiment à
la fois interne au territoire national
et international. On parlait de Dubaï
tout à l'heure, c'est une place de
blanchiment d'argent et dans nos villes,
moi j'ai vu fleurir des commerces qui
sont des commerces vides qui déclarent
des grosses chiffres d'affaires qui sont
des établissements de blanchiment. on
les connaît. Donc moi quand j'avais des
commerces, j'avais sans arrêt des
contrôles du SAAF ou l'importance du
travail et je ne comprends pas comment
ces établissements sont pas plus
contrôlés. Donc donc un répression
évidemment sur toute la filière euh du
deal trafic de euh répression
par des services de douanes et fiscaux
et tous les services de tout ce qui est
entrée du blanchiment mais trois. Ça
nécessite une action euh dans les
outresemers beaucoup plus fortes qui
sont des portes d'entrée euh de entre
autres pour la pour le marché de la
cocaïne. Le tout ce qui est ça nécessite
une action internationale puissante. On
parlait du Maroc tout à l'heure quand le
président de la République va au Maroc
et qui voit des champs de cannabis bah
s'il voit que des champs de cannabis
pour la consommation intérieur marocaine
thérapeutique c'est que il il a un
problème de cécité lui aussi. Contre la
la légalisation du cannabis ? Non moi je
suis je j'ai je suis devenu contre.
Voilà. Pourquoi vous étiez pour avant
quand vous étiez Non, parce que j'étais
peut-être plus libéral et plus
libertarien, je sais pas comment il faut
dire. Euh mais je me disais la
prohibition marche pas et compagnie.
Sauf que c'est la prohibition qui marche
pas ou c'est la guerre contre la drogue
? C'est la justement je pense
qu'aujourd'hui ce qui n'a pas fonctionné
c'est que on ne on ne peut pas on ne
peut pas faire ça à quart ou à moitié
temps. Donc ça nécessite cette triple
action internationale répressive et et
fiscale très très forte. Et si on n'est
pas sur parce que le problème c'est que
le le quand quand pays qui ont
dépénalisé
euh ou qui ont toléré plus où il y a
plein de régimes différents, ça tout le
temps, enfin moi ce que j'ai vu hein,
j'ai vu ça au Pays-Bas, j'ai vu
ailleurs, ça a ouvert complètement le
marché vers des transgressions qui se
font sur des sur des stupéfiants
beaucoup plus lourds. Donc je suis pas
sûr d'avoir raison là-dessus. Je je vous
le dis d'emblé, je c'est pas une réponse
péremptoire, mais je je je ne crois pas
que l'ouverture du la création d'un
marché de la drogue de du cannabis en
tout cas pardon
nous réglerait le problème. Je je pense
qu'il qu'il l'amplifierait le problème
sanitaire en déplaçant ce ce cette
économie dont ils se sont habitués à
vivre de façon somptuaire par une
économie clandestine et donc il faut
s'attaquer de façon extrêmement violente
sur le plan réfiscal et international.
Ça doit être dans les accords
internationaux. On on on se on se on
doit être capable de dire que si un pays
ne crame pas ses champs de cannabis de
pavau et cetera, on il il commet un acte
d'agression grave et et que ça peut
enclencher une spirale négative. Quelle
est votre lecture de ce qui se passe à
Los Angeles à l'heure actuelle sur les
les stupéfiants comme euh le fait que la
police la police de l'immigration Ah
pardon.
Écoutez, je
je sais pas quoi vous dire. Moi, je j'ai
pas me [__] à la place des dirigeants
américains quoi. Je Quelle est votre
lecture ? J'ai pas de lecture. Voilà, je
je peux pas vous dire. Objectivement, je
sais pas. Est-ce qu'on pourrait être
exposé au même type de manifestation ?
Oui, certainement. Oui, mais je l'ai pas
assez. Regardez objectif. On fait les
clandestin en France. Alors euh
je je je vais répondre à la question
parce que je ne contente pas les
questions. Vous êtes pas venu pour
pousser un cad hein pour répondre aux
questions. Non non non mais ce que je
veux dire c'est que je je je trouve
qu'on prend très souvent la question des
OQTF
que sous le mauvais aspect. C'estàd
qu'on pense que on focalise sur
l'immigration clandestine.
On doit d'abord focaliser sur
l'immigration légale parce que l'OQTF,
l'immigration clandestine, l'immigration
clandestine puis une partie EQTF vient
dans une grande mesure contrairement à
ce qu'on pense d'une immigration légale.
C'est qu'on focalise sur l'immigration
illégale, sur le bateau et ce et il faut
s'attaquer à cette immigration illégale
qui est dégueulasse euh qui tue des
gens. Euh c'est euh qui qui est sordide
que je vous discutez avec des personnes.
Moi je je suis dans un département qui
est très exposé à ça. Euh donc ça va un
peu mieux mais on a eu des grandes
vagues de d'immigration non seulement de
du Maghreb mais mais d'héritré beaucoup
d'héritréens
et puis on une ville d'accueil en plus.
par l'Italie et vous discutez avec des
des personnes vraiment misérables. Ça
c'est de la misère, de la pauvreté qui
ont tout laissé enfin bon et qui se
retrouvent à la rue avec des passeurs,
des salopards qui pardonnez-moi de faire
un peu de moraline pour le coup mais qui
donc ont exploité cette cette
réalité.
Mais pour revenir auour l'année dernière
en 2024 nous la France a délivré euh
toute forme confondu y compris que le
droit d'asile quasiment 500000 titres de
séjour.
une immense partie de cette immigration
légale va devenir une immigration
illégale.
Et c'est là qu'il y a toute l'hypocrisie
du système.
Euh donc commençons
par il faut l'immigration zéro n'est ni
souhaitable ni faisable.
Ni souhaitable ni faisable.
Mais en revanche, on est aujourd'hui à
un niveau d'immigration qui est
insoutenable.
Donc c'est pour des raisons logement,
emploi, c'est une immigration de
peuplement. Ce n'est pas une immigration
économique contrairement à ce que nous
disent les immigrationnistes.
L'immigration économique est devenue
totalement minoritaire. On va dire oui
mais regardez pour les vendanger dans
les vignes et pour travailler au
restaurant à Cann rasser les fraises.
Ramasser les fraises. OK, très bien. On
manque de main d'œuvre. Mais cette
immigration-là est devenue totalement
minoritaire, quasiment marginale. Le le
le l'observatoire de l'immigration
démontre tous les chiffres et fait un
super boulot et démontre que c'est une
immigration de peuplement. Donc on doit
diviser, on doit le le niveau
d'acceptation moi que je vois c'est
moins de 80000 par an étudiant compris.
Donc vous voyez on est loin des 500000
hein. Et donc là-dessus, on doit d'abord
s'attaquer à cela. D'où la nécessité
pour contrôler ces flux, faire des
quotas comme tous les pays du monde et y
compris les grandes démocratie de
modifier de de sortir de l'étau des
jurisprudences des hautes cours
notamment de la Cour européenne des
droits de l'homme mais aussi du Conseil
d'État du Conseil constitutionnel donc
de modifier la Constitution pour
déterminer le droit de maîtriser le
peuplement de la nation comme un droit
fondamental faire des murs. Non non,
mais je je vous parle de droit déjà en
et aujourd'hui notre problème c'est
c'est pas euh c'est pas l'absence de mur
hein, forcément notre problème c'est
qu'on a pas c'est qu'on a même pas le
droit de dire qui on accueille. Enfin je
je veux dire il faut commencer par cela.
Les gens ils arrivent sur la première
pierre de ce mur, c'est déjà de faire un
droit de l'immigration qui nous
permettete sera un délit de sortir de
l'article 8 de la Cour européenne des
droits de l'homme qui a été interprété
de façon jurisprudentielle
qui consiste à dire que le droit de
constituer sa famille où l'on veut
l'emporte sur la capacité d'une nation
de maîtriser qui vient sur son
territoire national. Donc ça signifie
qu'il faut revoir la hiérarchie des
normes sur cette questionlà. Donc revoir
et donc qu'il faut revoir la
Constitution, qu'il faut réformer le
champ de l'article 11 de la Constitution
pour faire un référendum sur
l'immigration qui nous permette de
transcender ses jurisprudences. C'est la
première
pierre de l'édifice et ensuite d'avoir
des des systèmes de protection des
frontières européennes et des frontières
nationales qui soient plus efficaces.
Mais on va construire des murs. Pas
forcément. S'il faut faire un mur
quelque part, pourquoi pas faire un mur.
Moi, je j'ai pas de religion là-dessus.
C'est c'est pas mon souci. C'est c'est
c'est aux gens de dire "Ben mais la
Hongrie a le droit de maîtriser ses flux
migratoires. S'ils estiment que c'est
des murs, c'est pas à moi de le dire. il
paye 1 million d'euros euh par mois ou
par jour euh d'amende euré. Il y a j'ai
un critère et c'est là où c'est de
définir quel est à chaque mesure par
rapport à l'objectif qu'on se donne,
quel est le coût avantage. Donc je je
pense que la il y a il y a d'autres
moyens d'être plus efficace sur la
protection des frontières qui coûtent
moins cher et plus efficace. Mais si
quelqu'un me démontre que c'est ça, bah
ça sera ça. C'est pas le sujet. Le sujet
c'est d'être dans le droit, de respecter
le droit et d'être efficace et ensuite
de mettre les moyens de l'efficacité au
service de nos finalités.
Question internet que je vais reformuler
mais on va on va rester dans l'idée. On
est en 2027 le lendemain de la
présidentielle.
Le pays est en faillite. Il y a le FMI
qui débarque.
La Troyka, nous en France, pays du
général de Gaulle, la Troyka débarque.
La BCE nous fait les gros yeux. La
Commission européenne nous fait les gros
yeux. Vous faites quoi ? Faites oui avec
la tête. Vous faites quoi ? Principe de
base,
il n'y a la souveraineté
ne se partage pas. y compris avec des
troicas aussi bien intentionnés que
l'Union européenne, le FMI et cetera. La
sou les mots ont un sens. Le la
souveraineté le sens au mot, c'est
rajoute du malheur au monde. Mais le la
souveraineté,
c'est quoi le souverain ? C'est le c'est
le peuple le représentant. C'est le
dernier décideur. C'est le dernier
décideur. Donc il peut y en avoir qu'un.
Autrement, si vous avez deux décideurs
qui conduisent la bagnole, il y a c'est
l'accident assuré. On revient à la
métaphore automobile. Ça va me valoir
des copains encore ça. Le
donc ça marche aussi avec la voiture
électrique. Donc euh Oui, mais ils sont
même je pense qu'ils arriveront même à
la voiture électrique. Cet outil de
liberté qui qui consiste à partir quand
on veut, à l'heure que l'on veut, là où
on veut, avec qui on veut est impensable
pour tous les liberticides qui
voudraient faire notre bien malgré nous.
Je ferme la parenthèse. On parlera des
gu plus tard. le
donc pour revenir à à à votre à votre
question, euh la solution ne viendra que
de nous-même. On a encore en France la
capacité
de de de retrouver euh un niveau de
production, de régler nos comptes
publics. Donc avec l'équipe qui
m'entoura et l'équivalent du 21e siècle
des ruefs, des pin de tout des pompidou
tous ces gens de grande qualité et bien
nous libérons les forces de production
du pays.
Nous ferons en sorte que
l'investissement en France devienne
extrêmement rentable.
OK. Le FMI débarque. Nous nous nous je
j'ai pas ce plan que je propose et que
je prépare, il est bien mieux que celui
du du FMI. Donc le FMI comme on aurait
on aura même pas besoin de mur pour lui
dire de de de nous [__] la paix, de
nous laisser travailler. Ouais,
il est impensable impensable hein que le
sursaut de la France ne vienne pas des
Français de la France. C'est impensable
et c'est pas une incantation.
Non, ce n'est pas une incantation. Sur
des
pas foutus de respecter le code de la
route. Pardon ? Ils sont pas foutus de
respecter le code de la route. Mais
c'est pour ça qu'on est un peuple
créatif.
Ça n'a rien à voir. C'est c'est ça n'a
rien à voir. Quelle était la la question
suivante ? Bon, allez, je vous accorde
un petit joker parce que vous êtes sympa
et bienveillant.
Gentil. Oui, gentil. J'ai pas dit brave
he, j'ai dit gentil. Non, mais gentil,
c'est une vraie qualité. La
bienveillance, c'est un petit peu
condescendant, je trouve. Oui, c'est un
mot qui a été galvaudé.
Les Il y a des yachotes à can. Oui, il y
a des yautrusses.
Vous avez saisi ou pas ? Moi je saisis
rien mais les Vous avez saisi les
propriétés russes à C ? Alors il y en il
y avait pas tant de propriétés russes,
c'était surtout au Cap d'antib et et sur
et à la Villefranche euh mais je crois
qu'il y a une une propriété russe saisie
par l'État qui a fait son job. Faut la
vendre ou il faut pas la vendre ? Alors
la le problème sans déconner non non le
le
problème de de de cela, moi je suis pas
alors il fallait les saisir c'était
décidé. J'ai aucun aucun problème
là-dessus.
J'ai dans mon équipe des gens qui disent
qu'il faut les vendre parce ça fait des
recettes. Sauf que vous créez un
précédent qui fragilise complètement la
confiance que avec les des pays tiers.
Saxi demain, vous êtes en conflit avec
un autre pays euh que des parce que là
on parle pas de de biens qui
appartiennent à des dirigeants, on parle
d'apparati, de gens qui qui étaient
proches du régime plus ou moins. Mais
c'est pas la question. Si demain vous
êtes en conflit avec un autre pays, vous
créez un précédent extrêmement grave et
c'est une atteinte à la propriété. que
pour des raisons diplomatiques,
il faille être avoir la violence de
saisir le bien. Ça m'a jamais posé aucun
problème he collaborer avec les
histoires avec les autorités françaises
et je vous dis c'était contrairement à
un fantasme aussi c'était pas dans ma
commune qu' en avait le plus mais s'il y
en avait le plus je l'aurais dit il y a
pas de sujet il y a pas de sujet
là-dessus de toute façon c'est les
services fiscaux qui le savent mais la
revente de bien saisi étranger pose une
question fondamentale à terme du respect
de la propriété hein voilà donc moi pour
l'instant je j'attends encore je les
reprendrai pas quo à peu près 2h30 qu'on
fait 2h36 qu'on est en interview. Pas
mal. Est-ce qu'il y a un sujet que vous
souhaiteriez aborder avec nous ? Qu'on a
on peut pas tout traiter hein. Non, on
en fait il y a plein de sujets que qu'on
a pas traité. Il faut destituer Macron
le plus vite possible. Non, il faut pas
le destituer parce que je ne suis pas du
tout pour la destitution. En revanche,
je pense qu' que le président de la
République est devenu, je l'avais dit
sur une radio de service public en
octobre et ça m'avait évalu quelques
quelques griefs, mais euh je pense qu'il
est devenu le principal problème
aujourd'hui dans le champ
institutionnel. Pourquoi je vous dis ça
? On est à 2 ans d'une présidentielle et
comme disait la marionnette Chirac,
c'est long.
[__] c'est long 2 ans et que le
problème c'est que si demain on peut
pas, je crois qu'on ne peut pas
continuer avec
euh la représentation nationale
actuelle, avec l'Assemblée nationale
actuelle, on voit bien que il y a de
tels enjeux, il y a une telle nécessité
de remettre de l'ordre, de rétablir la
sécurité, de d'arriver à avoir un plan
de redressement des comptes publics, de
rétablir l'école, bon bref, tout ce
qu'on a esquissé depuis tout à l'heure
que il faut une politique cohérente,
faut apporter une alternative et il faut
qu'elle ait la légitimité populaire, il
faut que les gens votent pour ça. Donc
le l'outil ça peut pas être la
dissolution parce que on va pouvoir le
président va pouvoir à nouveau dissoudre
bah il peut à nouveau dissoudre
d'ailleurs puisque cela va faire un an
ou ça va faire un an mois de juillet
mais il y a aucune raison que les mêmes
causes ne produisent pas les mêmes
effets. On a un éclatement de l'offre
politique et de la demande politique qui
sera confirmée. Donc il faut retrouver
un alignement de planète d'efficacité.
Ça se dit comment ? Président de la
République, pas d'institution. Ça se dit
si ça se dit démission. C'est-à-dire que
je pense qu'il faudrait que le président
de la République dise "Écoutez, je
prends acte du rejet que j'ai fait à
travers les européennes et à travers la
les législatives. Je prends acte du fait
qu'on ne peut pas être dans avec un
gouvernement dont la seule finalité
c'est un jour de plus. Un jour de plus,
un jour de plus. Et pour qu'on passe à
une nouvelle phase démocratique du pays,
je démissionne. Mais il faut pas qu'il
démissionne et qui et qui tout de suite
il signe le décret de démission parce
que s'il démissionne et qu' signe le
décret, il y a que 30 entre je crois que
c'est entre 28 et 35 jours dans la
constitution. Faudit vérifier pour
l'élection. Je faais qu'il dise je
démissionnerai je sais pas moi, dans 3
ou 4 mois, ce qui nous permet enfin
d'avoir une campagne électorale. Non
mais non mais d'ici 3 4 mois, les
agences de notation elles vont se gaver
peut-être. Mais ce qui nous permettrait
d'avoir et donc de relè problème de
légitimité
et et donc face d'exposer les réalités,
d'exposer les projets et de de comparer
des des projets d'alternative puissante.
Quand vous serez à l'Élysée, vous allez
payer votre facture d'électricité ou pas
? Je ferai ce qu'il faut faire. Euh je
sais pas s'il faut payer sa facture
électricité, ça me paraît assez normal,
mais je pense qu'il la paye non ? La
facture électricité, je pense que le
logement, alors si vous voulez, moi je
connais pas ces problématiques parce que
quand vous êtes maire, vous n'avez pas
vous n'avez pas de logement, vous n'avez
pas de ticket resto que ma salade au
bureau je la paye hein et tous les
maires de France, ce qui est normal.
Est-ce que votre charmante épouse va
nous coûter une blinde comme Brigitte
Macron Non non non non, je sais pas si
Brigit Macron coûte coûte une blinde
mais mais je je peux déjà vous tit déjà
vous dire parce que que si demain je
Mais ça ça paraît dingue. Comment votre
femme comment votre femme elle prend le
fait que vous vous engagiez dans ce
panier de crabe ? Mais euh vous savez le
le d'abord je je enfin
j'ai eu la chance moi de rencontrer des
gens formidables dans dans cet univers
qui est pas le mien. J'ai commencé mon
engagement dans la vie publique avec un
quelqu'un d' qui s'appelle Ser Vien.
Ensuite, j'ai eu la chance d'avoir 25
ans avant de retourner dans le privé
mais d'être pendant 3 ans de travailler
avec Jacques Péissard qui était député
par Lconniier qui était avocat qui était
qui est un homme exceptionnel quoi. L'on
leier dans le Jura. Voilà. Magnifique.
Bah attendez moi quel est le meilleur
commerce de l'on l'on leier ? Pourquoi
je peux pas vous citer ? Parce que j'en
a plusieurs qui viennent à l'esprit
figurez-vous. Et genre on parle du même
si c'est un chocolatier. Non. Ah bah si,
du chocolatier extraordinaire. Et en
face du chocolatier parce qu'il y a
pelant pelant et en face du chocolatier
en face il y a notre épicier magique euh
je commence par un thé. Terrasse
magnifique terrasse c'est vrai vous avez
fait quand même vous vous avez traîné
vos bottes là-bas. OK. et et Terrasse
que j'adoris j'adorais je
malin enfin l'épicier le plus malin que
rencontré j'en ai pourtant rencontré des
malin épiciers comme j'avais dit une
fois je dans un un homme politique dont
je terra le nom mais qui était major de
plein de trucs j'avais dit écoutez vous
êtes tellement intelligent que vous
confierez pas une épicerie parce que
terrasse je lui confierai un ministère
tandis que lui je confir un ministère
mais moi les rencontré je leur confierai
des affaires parce qu'ils ont le sens
des échéances et de la responsabilité
individuelle et que tout le secret est
là et c'est difficile de le transformer
en langage
vous voyez de de le transformer Est-ce
que vous seriez prêt à sacrifier pour la
France vous ? Mais mais pardonnez-moi,
mais je viens de sacrifier déjà là
presque 3 he de vie hein depuis que je
vous réponds. C'est que j'aurais jamais
répondu à ça. J'aurais lu un bouquin,
j'aurais été avec mes gosses, je serais
allé faire du sport si j'avais pas
encore cette flamme là. et et ce qui et
ce qui est donc je vous le dis, je viens
de sacrifier 3 heures de vie que c'était
c'était pas désagréable mais le c'était
pas c'est pas offensant hein comme
remarque. Mais ce que je veux dire c'est
que le fait d'être là, de pas être soit
dans dans un commerce que j'aurais
monté, soit avec ma famille, soit avec
un bouquin, soit en train de de faire du
sport, mais mais ceci étant, c'est un
choix. Et vous voyez le la l'immense
à tout que je c'est c'est je sais pas du
tout pour avoir une sauce, mais c'est
que je je serais heureux dans l'après
aussi et ça vous donne des ailes quoi.
Qu'est-ce que vous avez autour du
poignet ? Ah c'est rien. C'est un truc
perso ça. C'est un truc pas de
signification particulière. C'est le
taux euh francisca. Voilà.
Vous avez fait l'armée ? Oui. Où ? Alors
j'étais euh j'étais à l'UNBC. Alors j'ai
fait mes classes. J'étais à l'ENBC euh à
Camp et après j'ai été affecté euh dans
des services de d'information.
Est-ce que vous avez trois bouquins à
conseiller à notre communauté ? Alors,
d'abord à conseiller, c'est je je ce
mot, je je peux vous dire des bouquins
moi qui m'ont euh qui m'ont bouleversé.
Le problème, c'est que j'en ai des
dizaines en fait. Ouais, trois. Non,
mais trois ça, je vais m'en vouloir
après ce que je m'attendais. 10.
Ben euh
alors le dernier livre de Bruno Lemer,
pardon. Euh,
j'allais dire sortir une vanne qui
aurait été pour le coup triviale. Non.
Euh
non, mais je sais pas, les fleurs du
mal. Allez, tiens, ça change une vie.
Euh
1984,
évidemment. Ferme. Bon là, oui, mais je
je veux pas faire que du Orvel.
L'œuvre de Gosini. Toute l'œuvre de
Gosini. Oui, mais tout Gosini. Tout
gosini.
Euh Maurice Leblanc, hein, c'est Lupin.
Euh,
c'est tellement c'est c'est pas du tout
une livre a tout tout bien sûr. Euh
évidemment
Frédéric d'art, ah San Antonio,
c'est c'est voilà, je je déteste les
choses intimes, mais avec mon frère, on
est les premiers à avoir eu le bac hein,
dans dans nos familles. Maintenant ça me
fait rigoler quoi de dire ça. Mais
parents étaient pêcheurs. Non, ça
c'était Oui, ça c'était les aïux côté
canois mais mes parents, ma mère était
danseuse étoiles, mon père était
footballeur professionnel et ils sont
reconvertis dans le commerce. C'est pour
ça que j'ai j'ai eu aussi des commerces
et et sportif de haut niveau. Oui, parce
que c'est une des vraies exigences la
danse comme le football d'ailleurs. Et
ma mère qui était qui qui est toujours
de ce monde et qui est formidable qui
est qui est voilà et famille de neuf
gosses, ma mère mieux pour le c'est pas
une reconstruction très modeste euh n'a
pas passé le certificat d'étude mais
comme elle dansait était sur les routes,
elle lisait beaucoup. Et donc j'ai eu la
chance la chance d'avoir et de de lire
de dévorer des des des des bouquins
notamment tout ça Antonio. J'ai lu
Antonio très jeune et ça a fait mon
éducation argotique et et sexuelle aussi
parce que c'est formidable c'est une
richesse de portraites et ça m'a fait
découvrir aussi des Alexandre Vialat par
exemple. Ouais blondin. Mais si on parle
là-dedans
je j'en oublie et je je m'en veux.
J'adore l'œuf de Kundera. Si voilà, je
je kundera c'est sublime. J'ai ça fait
partie des livres que je relis avant de
mourir. Je veux relire aussi des Tolstoy
et de Toveski, les grands russes. Quand
quand version originale euh non en
version originale non parce que je dis
pas le russe mais en version bien
traduite euh parce que ça a été
retraduit de Chirac, c'est ça ?
Garpo mais euh la la Non non mais c'est
aussi euh voilà c'est c'est tout enfin
je je l'esprit David Lodge si on parle
d'un auteur britannique qui qui est qui
est qui est formidable mais je là on
part dans un domaine essentiel mais croy
en Dieu et la poésie Oui. Quelle poésie
?
Alors, tout à l'heure, j'ai cité les
fleurs du mal.
Euh mais
[Musique]
la la la poésie lorsqu'elle est en vert,
la poésie avec des une mal armée,
pardon, une écriture complètement
dissonnante et et créative. Mais j'aime
bien même la poésie un peu pompier moi.
Victor Hugo Patou mais Paul Valériite
j'aime ça. Mais aussi la poésie
la poésie qu'on voit qu'on sait qu'on
sait voir tous les jours, mais la poésie
de la musique.
J'ai j'ai aussi beaucoup d'admiration
pour les les les cinéastes
ou les musiciens qui savent quelle
poésie. Quelle poésie maintenant ? Quel
film ? Un seul.
Un seul.
Non, j'en diraiis pas un seul mais ça
marche. The of life de terrain malic.
Est-ce que vous avez un conseil pour les
jeunes générations ? Le le trè homme
euh Citizen Kane Norson Wells. Il veut
plus partirin.
Non parce que vous savez pourquoi c'est
formidable ? Parce que quand on parle
mais j'ai j'ai d c'est une façon de de
parler de soi tout en restant de c'est
si vous voulez. Je je je pense qu'il
faut rester pudique.
Alors dire je pudique c'est déjà un peu
contradictoire mais qu'il faut aussi une
part d'intériorité que les les il faut
dévoiler une part d'intériorité et c'est
la différence entre la pudeur et et
l'exhibitionnisme. Donc les œuvres d'art
permettent de se connecter aussi. Et
vous connaissez la mém éthique ? Non,
enfin je sais ce que c'est mais je je
mêque non mais je peux pas vous dire.
Voilà, je on peut communiquer comme ça
avec la mém éthique que ce soit la
mémétique visuelle,
le langage vernaculaire de la musique.
Ah les langues verniculaires aussi. Mais
la donc vous voyez quand quand Bertrand
Burgala
j'avais adoré un jour quelqu'un lui dit
"Vous faites de la musique d'ascenseur ?
On discute, il dit "Oui, mais moi je
mets de la poésie dans l'ascenseur." Moi
j'adore ça. Oui. Un conseil pour les
jeunes générations, une bouteille à la
mer, quelque chose qui restera
impérissable sur les réseaux avant que
les Américains nous le coupent.
Il y a tout est impérissable dans ce qui
fait la substance française, hein. Alors
là, pardon, mais j'ai pas d'inquiétude
là-dessus. Sir de Berger. Voilà. Conseil
pour les jeunes générations. Mais il y a
rien de pire donner un conseil aux
jeunes génération, c'est de pas écouter
les conseils des vieux. c'est de c'est
de d'avoir une profondeur historique
mais surtout de de d'embrasser la vie
quoi. C'est d'être un peu égoïste quand
on est jeune et puis plus on vieillit
d'aller vers les autres parce que au
début il faut se constituer soi-même, il
faut s'endurcir. C'est d'apprendre à
compter, d'apprendre à parler, c'est de
d'aimer le 21e siècle. C'est de surtout
pas écouter toute le la nostalgie de que
qu'on développe tous là. Non non non,
c'est non. C'est et puis et puis de se
dire que que que voilà que le que qu'il
y a des Molières aujourd'hui que Molière
parle toujours que que Nougaro il y a il
y a 50 ans moi m'a amené quand j'étais
petit à la langue française, je suis fou
de Nougaro et qu'aujourd'hui quand
j'écoute Aurelsan euh ça réinvente aussi
et c'est magnifique de poésie et que
donc de de de voilà c'est tout d'être
indépendant, d'être indépendant, d'être
indépendant, de pas dépendre des autres.
A c'est le seul conseil qu'on peut
donner. Mais c'est même pas un conseil,
c'est de permettre d'être indépendant.
C'est c'est différent. David Lissard,
merci. Merci à vous.
[Musique]